bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce qui
sera je l'espère notre saga de l'été
il s'agit de cours de paléo mammalogie
il s'agit des cours de paléo
mammalogique je donne ici en afrique du
sud niveau master et vous avez été
nombreux à me demander de mettre en
ligne des cours comme j'avais fait pour
le pour les cétacés et bien voilà
j'espère que ce sera notre fil rouge de
l'été une vidéo par semaine un cours de
paléo mammalogie par semaine et on
commence du coup aujourd'hui avec un
petit aperçu général d'une part de la
diversité des mammifères au mésozoïque
mais surtout de la phylogénie des
mammifères comme ça on évacue la
phylogénie dès la première dès le
premier cours et on a pu aller revenir
dessus mais vous verrez que la
phylogénie en elle-même c'est un très
très gros morceau donc sans plus
attendre commençons avec la paléo
mammalogie alors comme il s'agit de mai
courant des cours que je donne en
afrique du sud
vous allez voir que d'une part c'est
tout en anglais mais bon moi ça donne un
petit côté international voilà on est
comme ça on est généreux avec le langage
et surtout
vous allez voir que c'est trés african
au centre et c'est à dire que je montre
surtout des fossiles qui sont trouvés en
afrique
pourquoi pas pour la simple raison que
si vous regardez les livres de cours ils
sont tous écrits par des américains ou
des anglais de à ma connaissance il en a
pas qui était écrit récemment en
français mais voilà ils sont tous écrits
par des américains ou des anglais et
donc c'est que des exemples qui viennent
ou d'europe ou d'amérique ou d'asie et
très peu qui viennent d'afrique donc du
coup là c'est très africaine au centre
et histoire finalement de donner à mes
étudiants la capacité de voir ce qui se
fait sur leur continent
sachant que la capacité de voir ce qui
se passe ailleurs ils l'auront dans
n'importe quel bouquin en gros donc donc
mais je vais vous donner les exemples
équivalent en europe et je vais essayer
de trouver notamment des exemples qui
touche à la france et qui sont
équivalents à ce que je montre ici donc
là par exemple on a on va commencer par
les mammifères mésozoïque donc les
masques on doit ce qu'on doit appeler
normalement les mâts malia forme
mésozoïque parce que finalement les ce
qu'on appelle les mammifères du clad
mamma mia
ce sont les mêmes c'est l'ancêtre commun
des mots notres m des marsupiaux et des
placentaires et tous ceux et tous les
descendants de cet ancêtre commun et il
se trouve que les choses qu'on appelle
les mammifères au mésozoïque ne sont pas
forcément descendants de cet ancêtre
commun et c'est pour ça qu'on les
appelle des mama la forme et pas des
m'as malia donc pas des vrais mammifères
ce sont des mammifères aux morts est
donc le plus ancien mais ce ne sont déjà
plus des signaux dont tu
c'est à dire les ancêtres des mammifères
mais ça ça fera l'objet d'une autre
d'un autre cours on les fera sur la fin
les sino donc juste pour rappeler ce que
c'est que l'origine finalement des
mammifères donc là ce que vous voyez à
l'écran et bien ce sont les maliens
forme du mésozoïque donc les mâts malia
forme du mésozoïque typiquement ce sont
des animaux qui sont qui ressemble à des
musaraignes pas des rongeurs par pitié
ne dit plus qu'il ressemble à des
rongeurs les rongeurs sont des
herbivores ultraspécialisés les
mammifères ressembler à des musaraignes
et ressemblaient à des musaraignes parce
qu'ils étaient tous insectivores
globalement nocturne ou presque tous
nocturne donc d'où la baisse au niveau
de l'acuité visuelle la plupart des
mammifères ont hérité de cet ancêtre
nocturne l'absence fallait il la perte
de deux cônes sur les quatre que
qu'avaient les ancêtres des amiotte donc
la perte de la vision des couleurs au
final et la plupart des mammifères ne
voit pas les couleurs a pas l'exemple
l'exemple des primates dont nous sommes
fiers mans représentants donc voilà
ancêtres nocturne insectivores donc avec
des dents très pointue très comique mais
avec des molaires complexe ce qui les
distingue de leurs ancêtres les sino
d'hondt un cerveau globalement plus gros
que se dessine au donc donc ici vous
voyez c'est le cerveau de mai gaz austro
donc y ait cet animal que vous voyez là
vous voyez que les hémisphères cérébraux
sont bien développées comparer un
synodaux qui a un cerveau tubulaire qui
est très très semblable à celui des
reptiles et surtout et bien il
il avait très probablement la capacité
de pondre des oeufs
les marques les marsupiaux et les
placentaire ne pompe pas neuf mais les
mots notres m
donc le l'ornithorynque et les équipes
néo pop de2 donc par extension les
mammifères les maliens forme qui sont
plus primitive que ces mammifères
de ce point de vue là devaient pendre d
eux donc
donc quand on vous dit que le
marsupilami est un mot notre aime parce
qu'il pour dec pas vrai il ya beaucoup
de maliens forme qui pondent des oeufs
très probablement la quasi entièreté des
mama la forme du mésozoïque et donc
qu'est ce que ces mammifères mésozoïque
on encaisse que c'est ma malia forme
mésozoïque ont en commun avec les six
noms dont tu es bien ce sont les choses
que tous les synapses ide ont en commun
à savoir la fosse temporal et la
distinction de la dentition donc ici
vous voyez il ya une canine dans la
dentition qui sépare des incisives de
prémolaires et de molaires et ça c'est
propre à tous les synapses id donc ce
qui fait des mêmes d'emma malia forme
mésozoïque mais aussi des mammifères
modernes des membres du clac des
synapses id mais comme je l'aï dit nous
verrons tout cela dans une prochaine
vidéo alors le l'évolution depuis les
synapses ids ancestraux jusqu'au malia
forme ce
se caractérise par de nombreuses
tendances évolutives et il y a notamment
la perte
enfin une simplification général du
crâne donc ça c'est un crâne de
mammifères typique ça c'est un crâne
dame mignotte basalte hippiques donc
d'un synap cite par exemple et donc vous
voyez que toute la région autour de
l'orbité a été simplifié à seulement
trois os qui sont le frontal le lacrymal
et le jus galles et avec une
participation du square mozal chez les
mammifères pour faire le tour de leur
[ __ ] complètement et on a une perte
aussi du quadra taux du gal et une perte
de la série qu'on appelle poste pariétal
donc c'est à l'arrière de l'os pariétal
vous voyez la perte de ces trois oeufs
ici que sont le supra temporal le
tabulaire le post pariétal donc le crâne
des mammifères est plus simple que celui
de leurs ancêtres synapses id
donc quand on vous dit que l'évolution
forme des individus complexe voilà un
contre exemple magnifique
bon ça rend pas le crâne des mammifères
si simple que ça pour autant et voici
donc la mosaïque des eaux que vous
trouvez à l'intérieur des mammifères
donc ça c'est juste pour information
évidemment c'est pas c'est pas une
information les informations qu'il ya
sur cette image ne sont pas capitale
pour comprendre l'évolution des
mammifères heureusement mais si jamais
vous êtes un peu perdu ni vos os
théologie voilà vous pouvez toujours
vous référer à ce moment-là de la
présentation c'est au cas où c'est un
peu la galère pour vous rappeler du nom
de tous ses eaux
alors il ya une idée préconçue et une
idée que je véhicule moi même évidemment
parce que c'est tellement simple et
facile à
un véhicule et c'est que les mammifères
les maliens forme du mésozoïque vivait à
l'ombre des dinosaures comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure c'était typiquement des
petit insectivore nocturne qui qui ont
attendu la dent sagement dans un coin
que les dinosaures crève pour pouvoir
prendre leur place au cénozoïque c'est
vrai dans les grandes lignes mais on va
voir que justement les prochaines slide
sont dédiés justement la diversité des
mammifères des mama la forme mésozoïque
pour montrer que c'est pas si simple que
ça en réalité c'est vrai dans les
grandes lignes ça l'est moins dans le
détail et on est notamment vous pouvez
voir à travers cette phylogénie donc
tout à l'heure on a vu mais gaz austro
dont qui fait partie de la famille des
morganucodon codante idée du
morganucodon qu'on trouve en angleterre
donc c'est pas très loin de chez nous et
il n'est pas complètement impossible
qu'on trouve un morganucodon en france
un jour notamment dans l'est on a de
très beaux mammifères du mésozoïque dans
l'est de la france à sa laurent de porc
si je me rappelle bien donc donc on ad
on a du mal y'a forme en france et il
n'est pas impossible qu'un jour on
trouve du morgen du coton ou du
morganucodon idée mais vous voyez qu'il
n'ya pas que les morganucodon idée il ya
aussi des docks aux dons des australes
hausse fait une idée d autres icônes au
don't des multi tubercules et qui passe
même la limite crétacé tertiaire et
perdure jusqu'à l'oligocène ce sont des
sons des mammifères qui ressemblaient à
des rongeurs et qui ont fini par être
remplacé par les vrais rongeurs pendant
le ces deux os x vous avez laisse pas la
cote et ridé bon bref vous avez tous ces
noms et au final quand vous analysez
bien les australes hausse fait une idée
ils ont donné les mots notres m et vous
avez les bords eos penida donc ce que
l'aide là qui a survécu grâce aux mets
ta terriens qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
les marsupiaux et les aux terriens dont
les survivants sont les placentaire donc
en fait aujourd'hui on a trois grand
clad de mammifères ces trois grands clad
là alors que mésozoïque il y avait 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 et 9 et 10 passes que les aux
terriens m
therrien était déjà là au mésozoïque au
moins au crétacé donc au crétacé on a
quand même une deux trois quatre cinq
six sept huit neuf familles de
mammifères enfin de malia forme donc la
diversité des mammifères en fait
aujourd'hui elle est réduite par rapport
à celle qu'on avait au mésozoïque donc
déjà c'est un premier point et ça a été
très bien démontré par des articles
récents c'est que en fait on aujourd'hui
on a une diversité en termes de famille
qui est réduite par rapport à enfin en
termes de super ordre pardon parce qu'on
va pas appeler tous des familles en
termes de super ordre on a une diversité
qui est réduite de mammifères et ça je
trouve que c'est quand même cool quoi de
dire bah non en fait au mésozoïque nos
ancêtres il poutre est quoi il pourrait
dans le petit mais il coûterait voilà et
vous voyez là la diversité des dents
qu'avaient les mammifères à l'époque des
danses de type 6 métro dont djoko dont
tricot 90 multi tuyaux mais reculé
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que des dents
de type
tribos fait ni qu on va voir tout à
l'heure ce que ça veut dire mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus qu'un seul
type de dents chez les mammifères c'est
le dent tribos phoenix alors qu'avant il
y avait tout ça voilà donc là je vais
vous montrer quelques exemples de petits
mamaya forme du mésozoïque juste
histoire qu'on s'amuse un peu donc là
vous avez par exemple castoro coda qui
est un mammifère donc du mésozoïque qui
vivait au temps des dinosaures mais qui
est en fit bien amphibiens et comment on
le sait enfin amphibie par amphibiens
qui est amphibie semi aquatique
comment on le sait quand on regarde le
fossile on voit que ça que a des
vertèbres aplati latéralement comme
celles d'akka store et ya même la
préservation des tissus mous autour qui
montre que il avait la queue plate comme
celle d'un castor donc castoro coda
était finalement l'équivalent d'un
castor de l'époque
excepté qu'il était piscivores et non
pas herbivores comme le sont les castors
et castoro coda il a aussi cette
particularité c'est qu'il vient de la
fin du jurassique et qu'il a des poils
bien préservés sur le fossile et ça ça
fait de lui la première
apparition des poils dans le registre
fossile des mammifères avant ça on n'a
pas de poils dans le registre fossile
des mammifères donc c'est plutôt cool
castoro coda il montre bien voilà le la
diversité que pouvaient avoir les
mammifères à l'époque et en afrique il
ya cet exemple de xxi yokono d'ong qui
était un mammifère amalia forme du
mésozoïque avec des dents qui ressemble
à celle d'un requin finalement d'où son
nom il faut que nos dons donc des dents
coniques de poisson évidemment le
célèbre et pénaux m'amuse du crétacé de
chine
dans l'intérieur duquel des petits hôtes
été trouvé et pas n'importe lesquels il
s'agit des eaux d'un bébé dinosaure donc
c'était un animal de la taille de la
taille d'un chien et qui bouffaient du
bébé dinosaure et ça c'est quand même
plutôt cool et ça montre que les
mammifères étaient effectivement pas que
des des petit insectivore nocturne et en
afrique
il y a un exemple en angola de très très
grosses voire très très grosse pour
l'époque évidemment mais voilà une
empreinte de 3 cm qui appartient à un
mammifère cette petite empreinte de pas
elle est déjà plus grosse que tout le
corps du méga sauce trop donc je vous ai
montré donc encore une fois on n'est pas
sûr du mammifère
on n'est pas sûr du petit mammifère lé
maillot pas thallium de la famille des
haras maïda est un mammifère qui a des
qui a finalement une membrane donc un
passage yom c'est de là que vient son
nom un maillot pata gionne la mer au
passage y sommes et qui est très très
bien préservé on voit ici il n'y a pas
vraiment de doute la préservation des
tissus mous montrent clairement que
c'est pas une invention il y avait bien
un passage y sommes tendus entre les
entre les bras mais aussi entre les
jambes de cet animal qui le faisait
ressembler à un écureuil volant mais
aucun rapport avec les écureuils volants
il s'agit d'un art à mme haïder donc un
très proche parent finalement 2
demaegdt asos trop donc on a vu tout à
l'heure et des morganucodon idée les
multis tubercules et dont je parlais
tout à l'heure qui ressemblaient à des
rongeurs donc voilà ils tiennent leur
nom d'un des multiples tubercules de
leurs dents comme vous pouvez voir ici
des multi tubercules et on en trouve
partout dans le monde ils ont un énorme
succès évolutif
alors celui là il est marrant parce
qu'il vient des carpates et il a les
dents rouges donc il fait vraiment
penser à un vampire
les dents ont été préservés comme ça
avec du rouge dessus bon c'est quelque
chose qu'on trouve encore aujourd'hui
chez des musaraignes par exemple il ya
certaines musaraigne qui ont les dents
rouges parce qu'elles sont enrichis en
faire et alors lui en plus il a cette
espèce de tronçonneuse sur le sur les
sur les prémolaires inférieur donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle une dent plage viola
coheed donc c'est une des prémolaires en
fait qui se transforme en je sais pas on
dirait une scie circulaire quoi elles
bougent pas évidemment ce n'est pas une
vraie scie circulaire mais voilà et là
on est sur du on est sûr de l'herbivore
ultraspécialisés avec les multi
tubercules et encore un autre herbivore
ultra spécialisés mais contrairement au
multi tubercules et vous pouvez voir
qu'il était d'assez grande taille delà
de la taille d'un bon gros castor aussi
comme tout à l'heure et il s'agit de
ville tana et alors ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec ventana c'est qu'il a
été trouvé à madagascar donc c'est un
représentant d'une faune assez
différente du reste finalement mais il a
ses grosses dindes rongeurs dont qu'il a
il al'allure général d'un castor il a
des grosses dents de rougeurs et il a
cette espèce de truc là en dessous de
l'arcade zygomatique donc ici vous avez
l'oeil et là vous avez l'arcade
zygomatique il a cette espèce de
processus qui s'étend vers le bas et
quand on voit l'intérieur en fait on
voit que c'est une grosse zone
d'insertion pour le muscle master donc
c'est la joue en fait c'est le muscle
qui forment la jouer donc c'est cet
animal avait une puissance de
mastication dans les joues qui était
ahurissante et on voit aussi une très
très grande crête sagittale pour
l'insertion du muscle temporal donc très
forte puissance mastic actrice les dents
sont en croissance continue les molaires
sont en croissance continue donc et avec
une surface très très plate est
complètement érodé donc on est vraiment
sur un sur sur un mammifère qui imite
complètement le mode de vie des rongeurs
mais encore une fois ce n'est pas un
rongeur
mais toute cette magnifique diversité de
mammifères mésozoïque au bout d'un
moment elle va rencontrer la très
glorieuse et
et mortelle limite crétacé tertiaire la
limite crétacé paléogène comme on
l'appelle des fois et les mammifères
n'ont pas fait exception enfin les mâts
malia forme n'ont pas fait exception ils
ont pris cher dans leur phase est donc
ici vous avez là c'est l'exemple des
marsupiaux notamment les marsupiaux ont
salement morflé donc mais tous les
mamies et oulémas malia forme je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure la phylogénie vous
aviez l'extension il ya que les multi
tubercules et les
les australes hausse pénide et donc les
ancêtres des mots notres m et les
placentaire et les marsupiaux qui
passeront au travers mais comme j'ai dit
ça se fera pas sans heurts donc c'est
une idée préconçue que c'est une idée
commune que les mammifères ont survécu à
la limite crétacé tertiaire mieux que
les dinosaures mais pas tant que ça dans
la mesure où les dinosaures aujourd'hui
sont dix mille espèces alors qu'il ya
que 5000 espèces de mammifères
au final les dinosaures ont mieux
survécu à la crettaz à la crise
crétacé-tertiaire que les mammifères
donc voilà maintenant qu'on a vu fait
passer en revue un petit peu ces
mammifères mésozoïque on va voir ce qui
arrive du côté des véritables mammifères
donc le clad mammal ya donc le clan de
mamma mia qui je le rappelle comprend
l'ancêtre des mots note comprend
l'ancêtre des monos traîne des
marsupiaux et des placentaires et tous
ses descendants donc il faut tracer la
ligne et des mots notres md placentaire
et des marsupiaux pour aller chercher
leurs ancêtres en commun qui se trouve
ici
donc ça là c'est l'ancêtre commun des
maliens et donc vous voyez que cet
ancêtre commun des maliens on le trouve
profondément dans le mésozoïque ici au
jurassique donc déjà premières
informations les mâts malia les vrais
malia ne sont pas n'apparaissent pas
après le sénat après le début du
cénozoïque comme c'est souvent 10 dans
les reportages en réalité il était déjà
là bien avant
alors comment distingue-t-on ces trois
familles de mammifères modernes
donc vous avez les mots notres m qui
sont les plus basses eaux et vous avez
les marsupiaux et les placentaire et
esquive à les distinguer en fait c'est
leur biologie reproductrice donc les
mots notres m
évidemment sont ceux qui pondent des
oeufs les marsupiaux sont ceux qui
donnent naissance à des bébés qui vont
grandir dans une poche
ce que vous voyez ici et les placentaire
sont ceux qui donnent naissance à des
bébés qui sont immédiatement formé et
quasiment autonome dès la naissance
donc voilà des oeufs bébé dans la poche
marsupial qui n'est pas tout de suite
autonome et mammifères quasiment
autonome dès la naissance
bon évidemment il ya différents degrés
de ce que j'appelle autonomie mais en
gros voilà par exemple un chat n'est pas
tout à fait autonome quand il naît voyez
un bébé chatons il n'a pas les yeux
ouverts mais çà çà çà c'est un marsupial
quand il est quand il naît ça c'est un
kangourou dont vous voyez ce que
j'appelle autonome pas du tout autonome
voilà c'est des petits là c'est des
petits vers les pauvres marsupiaux
cantine s alors les mamans leur font une
petite autoroute entre le vagin et la
poche
pour qu'ils puissent escalader les poils
voilà donc avec leurs petites mains ils
font des petites autoroute pour que le
la larve marsupial escalade les poils
jusqu'à la poche mais voilà le s'il n'y
a pas la poche
il n'y a pas de marsupial envie là c'est
ça que je veux dire par autonomy donc ça
ça s'appelle un petit altri sial et ça
c'est un petit précoce voilà donc ils
développement précoce développement
altri sial donc développement prolongée
après la naissance et donc vous voyez
que la halle tricia leigh t c'est quand
même plutôt un caractère primitif
puisque les mots notres aime quand ils
naissent qui sortent de leurs oeuvres
il ressemble aussi à des petites larves
donc voilà mais quand même l'absence de
zfs feu soutient le clad que forment les
marsupiaux et des placentaires qui
s'appelle le cloud et herria donc à
l'intérieur des teria vous avez les méta
teria que sont les marsupiaux et les
hôtes et ria que sont les mammifères
placentaires ya aussi une autre
curiosité au niveau de la biologie
reproductrice c'est donc chez les
mammifères placentaires et marsupiaux
donc celle et herria encore une fois on
a une division des sexes qui est
typiquement malienne avec les mâles qui
sont xy et les femelles qui sont xx donc
les mâles sont hétérozygotes pour les
et chromosomes sexuels alors que les
femelles sont homozygotes est bien chez
les mots notres m
c'est pas le cas ce sont les mâles qui
sont homozygotes et les femelles qui
sont hétérozygotes donc les mâles sont
zz et les femelles sont z w exactement
comme chez les reptiles les oiseaux etc
donc ça c'est le caractère primitif et
donc les monogrammes sont assez curieux
de ce point de vue là on sait pas trop
comment ça s'est fait finalement cette
transformation des chromosomes sexuels
mais il ya un moment où il ya un truc à
un moment il ya un truc qui a changé est
donc ce qui va caractériser ces
mammifères
tous ces mammifères c'est le la dans
tribos phoenix donc la dent tribos
phoenix
comme vous pouvez le voir c'est une dent
qui a 3 caunes qui ne sont pas alignés
mais qui forment un triangle donc le
protocole le par à caunes est le méta
caunes donc primitivement normalement on
a trois caunes donc c'est ce que vous
pouvez voir ici
primitivement on a trois communes qui
sont alignés d'avant en arrière donc
c'est ce qu'ont touché les sino d'hondt
et finalement les culs speed accessoires
vont se déplacer latéralement vers
l'extérieur pour former le protocole
pour former le par akon est le méta
caunes et le cône du milieu devient le
protocole donc protocole parra codm et
akon c'est sur les dents du dessus est
sur les dents du dessous on a
l'équivalent qui sont le protocole id
part inconnu nommé tacconi d' et un
talent onid un talent owni qui est lui
même formé de trois cuts speed que sont
lentes auconie de l'ipo kony et l'ipo
connu lead talent onid qui sert
finalement à l'occlusion du protocole
donc ça ce protocole la vient former un
pilon qui est ce et le talent onid
format bassin et finalement le pilon
vient broyer la nourriture dans le
bassin donc ce qui va vraiment
caractériser les mammifères c'est la
mastication de la mastication grâce à la
danse tribos phoenix qui permet de
finalement de pilonner la nourriture à
l'intérieur de la bouche donc c'est le
muscle master va être aussi très
important chez les mammifères puisque
ils forment les joues c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le muscles zygomatiques
aussi
elle appelle le muscles zygomatiques il
est attaché à l'arcade rugal ou arcade
zygomatique et ils forment les jouets
les joues c'est ce qui retient la
nourriture à l'intérieur de votre bouche
et qui vous permet aussi de mâcher
puisque c'est un muscle qui se contracte
pour ramener la mâchoire du bas contre
la mâchoire duo donc la combinaison dans
tribos phoenix joue et mieux fait part à
muscle master sa caractérise les
mammifères voilà et tout cela permet la
mastication
donc c'est une sont des caractères très
important et donc la dent tribos phoenix
est la seule qui existe encore
aujourd'hui on a vu plein d'autres types
dentaire avant qu'ils n'ont rien donné
après la crise crétacé-tertiaire cela
dans tribos phoenix est la seule qui
fonctionne encore aujourd'hui donc mais
à partir de ce schéma tribos panique et
bien les mammifères ils vont partir
complètement en sucette
voilà donc avant ça vous aviez des
poissons des reptiles des des poissons
des reptiles et des reptiles malien donc
des thérapies site qui n'avait qu'une
seule qu speed sur leurs dents donc une
seule puce piste qui voulait être plus
ou moins agrémenté de d'autres dents ou
plus ou moins crénelés voilà selon que
vous étiez à beaver ou carnivores plus
ou moins recourbé mais voilà sa limite
et beaucoup la variation après chez les
mammifères à partir de ce schéma tribos
phoenix vous allez avoir des dents aussi
bizarre que celle là donc ça c'est un
crabe pieters il donc c'est le phoque
crabiers vous allez avoir des dents
extrêmement complexes comme celle de la
souris vous allez à ou bien celle de
celles d'autres rongeurs ici que
donc les vole ce sont les loire ici vous
avez un wallaby là vous l'avez une vache
donc vous allez avoir tout les types de
dents qui vont évoluer à partir de cette
date rim os phoenix des dents très
coupantes comme celle du lion d'aidantes
écrasante comme celle de l'homme du
panda on voit là la mastication et la
complexité du dessin dentaire c'est la
signature des mammifères malia et à
partir de là il ya des types dentaire
qu'on a mis en place et qui vont
caractériser chaque groupe de mammifères
ces types dentaire si on veut comprendre
l'évolution des mammifères et si on veut
regarder les mammifères fossiles être
capable de les identifier
bon je suis navré mais il faut en passer
par là il faut les connaître donc donc
c'est pareil je vous invite à revenir
ici à ce point de la vidéo aussi souvent
qu'il le faudra parce que je vais pas
rappeler à chaque fois ce que ce que
veulent dire ces termes parce que ça
prendrait trop de temps donc je vais les
expliquer une bonne fois pour tout ici
est comme ça tous ces types dentaire
après vous pourrez revenir à cet endroit
de la vidéo pour comprendre de ce que ça
veut dire donc déjà on va distinguer
deux types dentaire en fonction de la
hauteur de la couronne donc ces deux
petits d'antibes dentaire ses bras qui
dont tu es ips sont donc les dents bras
qui dompte c'est une couronne dentaire
basse donc ici vous avez la limite
gencives extérieur en pointillés donc
vous avez soit la couronne basse et dans
ce cas là vous êtes bras qui donc où
vous avez une couronne haute voire très
haute et dans ce cas là vous êtes ipso
d'hondt
donc voilà l'humain a typiquement une
couronne basse vous voyez ici la limite
entre les racines et la couronne la
couronne est relativement basse c'est
typiquement une dent bras qui dompte
c'est le type primitif les chevaux eux
ont une dent traits dérivés
ils ont les dents avec des couronnes
très très hot
parce qu'ils sont adaptés un régime
herbivores et herbivores voire même
graminées et les graminées elles quand
elles ont beaucoup de silice à
l'intérieur de leur cellule et 7 silice
elle est extrêmement abrasifs c'est un
mécanisme de défense contre les
herbivores et 7 silice extrêmement
abrasifs bien les herbivores vont
systématiquement et de manière
complètement convergentes évoluer des
dents à couronne très très hot donc des
dents ipso d'hondt qui vont continuer à
grandir même quand l'animal et adultes
afin qu'il y ait toujours un petit peu
dedans pour les pour les écraser et donc
que vous voyez ici c'est finalement un
mix ce que vous voyez sur cette surface
est la surface est extrêmement complexe
chez le cheval c'est finalement un mix
entre de l'émail mais aussi de la
dentine donc l'ivoire qui se trouvent
normalement à l'intérieur de l'émail
mais chez eux elle est complètement
exposées à cause de l'usure dentaire et
vous avez aussi du cément le segment qui
se trouve entre les entre les couche
d'émail finalement donc la dentine
représente l'intérieur de la dent et le
segment représente l'équivalent de la
dentine à l'extérieur de la dent donc
l'homme n'a pas vraiment de cément il ya
que les herbivores qui ont du sénat donc
ça c'est donc ça c'est la première chose
donc bracchi d'hondt
c'est un type dentaire qu'on va associer
globalement c'est le type dans terre
primitive qu'on retrouve chez les
insectivores les omnivores et les
carnivores
l'ipso dont 6 c'est le type qu'on
retrouve chez les herbivores et plus
particulièrement chez les grammy nos
bords je vais dire donc ceux qui ceux
qui mangent des graminées en anglais on
les appelle des greeters
donc on peut dire grameen over je pense
donc les les frugivores vont se
retrouver du côté bras qui donc par
exemple ceux qui mangent des feuilles
les follivores vont aussi être plutôt
bras qui donc où est l'intermédiaire
entre lipso dompter bras qui donc ce qui
évidemment on va voir qu'il n'ya pas de
limite solide entre les deux évidemment
que pendant l'évolution les groupes
d'herbivores vont commencer avec le type
primitif bracchi dont tu es vont être
des défauts lievore ou des fruits givors
et vont s'adapter au fil du cénozoïque
un régime plus gras mini bord ou pas
mais le cheval par exemple c'est un
exemple typique d'animal qui va évoluer
au fil du cénozoïque vers un type de
plus en plus hypes ce dont un type
dentaire de plus en plus isolantes
est ce dû à l'arrêt dit fication du
climat à la fin du mésozoïque il n'y a
pas d'herbe à la fin
du mésozoïque il n'y a pas d'herbe
cénozoïque commence il ya des forêts
partout le climat est extrêmement chaud
il n'y a pas de calotte glaciaire c'est
seulement à l'oligocène que la calotte
glaciaire va arriver la glaciation va se
produire pour la première fois au
cénozoïque à l'oligocène donc 30
millions d'années
il ya 30 millions d'années 2 à partir de
maintenant et c'est seulement là que les
savanes et les steppes vont se répandre
à travers le monde grâce à l'aridité
provoqué par cette glaciation donc la
glaciation elle refroidit le climat mais
elle retient l'eau aussi donc il ya
aridité et sa développement des savanes
et c'est seulement là qu'on va voir les
premiers ipso d'hondt se développer et
donc en plus de ces deux types dentaire
il y a le type il y a trois autres types
dentaire qui vont se superposer à cela
selon les types bruno dhont lofo dante
et celeno dont tu donc le type bruno
dhont c'est le c'est le type qui est le
plus proche de celui du type primitif
donc le type primitif scellé dans des
secteurs hors donc c'est là dedans
tribos phoenix que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure donc l'opossum
typiquement donc cd cd cdq speed qui
sont relativement haute et pointu bon
avec le type bruno dhont on est toujours
sur des culs speed relativement ronde
mais beaucoup moins pointu donc c'est
typiquement ce qu'on rencontre chez le
cochon et chez l'humain donc chez les
omnivores
on rencontre sachez l'ours aussi le type
bruno dhont donc le type bruno dhont
c'est là dans typique des omnivores et
ensuite vous avez les dents de
d'herbivores donc les dans l'eau
fondante et celeno dont tu donc on va
commencer par les dans l'eau faut donc
les dans l'eau chaude honte c'est assez
simple vous avez là le bord extérieur
qui forment un mur ou une muraille
dentaire et à l'intérieur vous avez 2 9
1 et 2 donc votre protocole ni les lave
par akon il est l'âme et à cosne il est
là et ça c'est l'ipo caunes important
l'ipo caunes il n'est pas là
primitivement donc si je retourne ici
vous voyez le protocole il est la parra
codm et à cosne et vous avez un petit
repli des mailles ici qu'on appelle un
saint guillaume qui formera l'ipo caunes
plus tard chez certaines espèces chez
d'autres
spèce l'ipo caunes ça va être le méta
qu'au nul qui s'est agrandie donc que ce
soit dans un cas ou dans l'autre ça
s'appelle anip aux cônes mais faut
savoir que l'ipo caunes est quelque
chose de convergence parce que ça vient
avec l'adaptation à l'herbe ivory donc
les primates que nous sommes nos
ancêtres étaient follivores et
frugivores ils ont développé un
hippocampe que vous voyez là proto
parham état et hypocrisie vous avez une
dent de rhinocéros donc voilà là dedans
en vrai vous avez une dent de rhinocéros
protoppas ram et à hypo et avec des
l'ofs
et ici vous avez la danse et les 90 qui
c'est typiquement la dent qu'on retrouve
chez les ruminants donc les vaches les
chèvres les serres les girafes
tout ça ça a des dents celeno dont tu es
là c'est pareil proto par a meta et
hippo caunes tout est là c'est de la
danse typique des herbivores avec quatre
cônes bien développé et la forme celeno
donc celeno dont tu donc très typique
des ruminants donc celeno d'onde parce
que en forme de croissant de lune tout
simplement
et enfin le type carnivores j'ai oublié
de le mentionner mais il ya évidemment
le type carnivores c'est très simple
donc vous prenez une dent
tribos pénique classique vous enlevez
vous enlevez une des trois cocus speed
vous gardez les deux sur le bord de la
dent et ça vous donne un énorme
tranchant que vous pouvez voir ici et
donc de cul speed avec une lame
tranchante au milieu c'est la danse
échos de la dent qui sert à couper donc
là vous avez une hyène par exemple bon
voilà et après vous faites des
combinaisons parce que ça se peut aussi
donc on peut faire des combinaisons
dedans bras qui bruno dhont donc des
dents à couronne basse et à morphologie
bruno dhont ça vous donne l'humain ça
vous donne le cochon ça vous donne la
dent typique des omnivores
vous avez des dents bracchi lofo d'onde
c'est typiquement ce qu'on retrouve chez
le tapir et c'est une dent typique de
follivores vous avez des dents ipso lofo
dont tu sais la dendre rhinocéros c'est
une dent de grameen ivor vous avez des
dents ipsos et leino dont tu sais la
dent typique des dévs hdd et des chèvres
par exemple donc c'est une dent
d'herbivores mangeurs de graminées c'est
que dont tu n'es jamais associé à l'ipp
ce dont 6 donc ça ça simplifie les
choses c'est toujours bras qui sait
codante donc on dit directement ses
codante celeno d'onde et quelquefois
associé à brac i don t dans ce cas là ce
sera plutôt follivores mes bras qui
celeno d'onde c'est plutôt un type
dentaire qui se rencontrent chez les ars
you dactyle de l'éocène donc on en
parlera rapidement mais voilà c'est un
type dedans qu'on rencontre pu vraiment
chez les espèces modernes et donc à
partir de ces types dentaire vous pouvez
dérivés absolument toutes les lignes et
de mammifères du monde et c'est ça qui
est formidable avec les mammifères c'est
vous n'avez besoin que des dents chaque
espèce et j'insiste dessus il n'ya rien
d'exagéré dans ce que je dis chaque
espèce à une morphologie de molaire
différentes
vous pouvez reconnaître une espèce de
mammifère rien qu'à sa morphologie
dentaire et l'évolution de ces de ces
types dentaire se suit de façon
merveilleuse dans le registre fossile
à partir de là dans tribos panique donc
c'est ce que vous voyez au milieu ici
vous pouvez dérivés tous ces types
dentaire et ils sont tous magnifiquement
documenté par le registre fossile donc
par exemple vous commencez avec la dent
tribos fait nick vous rajoutez un hip
hop comme ça vous donne une bande
primates
voilà une bande primates s'est jamais
qu'une d'entre ibos panique avec un hip
hop conan plus vous prenez la dent
tribos phoenix vous la simplifier à mort
vous obtenez la danse échos dont tu des
carnivores donc vous voyez là on allait
les culs speed latéral celles qui sont
vers l'extérieur le protocole vers
l'intérieur ont réduit les culs speed à
l'intérieur jusqu'à avoir une belle
l'âme et ça vous donne le type
carnivores vous développez le cette
forme plus ou moins en w que vous voyez
à l'extérieur vous le développer à mort
et vous obtenez les chiroptères avec
leurs dents dit zalando d'hondt vous
partez du côté des rougeurs et des del à
pas alors là vous rajoutez un hip hop
koné puis après c'est la fête vous
faites ce que vous voulez parce que les
rongeurs on va
voir c'est juste du grand n'importe quoi
leur morphologie dentelle ils ont tout
inventé
vous prenez la dent tribos panique vous
la rendez aux faux don de vous rajoutez
un hip hop comme vous développez la
halle au fond aussi et ensuite vous
rajoutez des l'ofs
voilà donc de l'offre chez moe
eritherium 1 2 3 et puis ensuite 4 et
puis ensuite jusqu'à des vingtaines de
l'ofs
mais c'est juste une multiplication des
lofts et vous obtenez un éléphant voilà
juste par multiplication des l'ofs
donc évidemment il ya des contraintes
génétique à tout ça mais mais à partir
du moment où le chemin à l'ajout dé
l'offre est ouvert dans l'évolution des
éléphants vous avez cette évolution à
partir d'une dent tribos panique
jusqu'à cette espèce de monstre qui a
une dent d'éléphant ça pèse jusqu'à 3 3
4 voire 5 kg une dent d'éléphant donc
c'est vraiment monstrueux mais tout ça
ça a commencé avec une dent tribos fait
[ __ ] c'est très bien documentées par
des fossiles
vous développez la halle aux fonds non
si du côté des périseaux dactyle et si
vous restez but naulleau faut donc ça
vous donne un tapir si vous donnez buno
si vous devenez
yp solofo d'onde vous devenez à
rhinocéros si vous donnez iep solo
fondante et que vous aimez vous
compliquer la vie
ça donne à cheval mais vous voyez que ça
commence avec du lot fondante le lot feu
dont tu deviens ips augmenté après sakho
après il ya des ja ddq speed additionnel
qui se développe et qui s'usent ce qui
donne la morphologie du cheval mais on
reconnaît toujours proto par a meta et
hip hop comme chez le cheval et puis
vous avez la lignée des arts cieux
dactyle donc avec le développement de la
cedeao dont 6 que vous pouvez suivre de
ce côté là chez les ruminants ici ou
bien le développement de la bulle au
dossier chez les cochons et d'une alors
une
dunod dont 6 additionné à de l'ipso dont
six qui est aussi unique à l'hippopotame
donc on peut être bu nos dons et hips
don't lie potable est un bon exemple
donc voilà ça c'est la magie des dents
chez les mammifères vous pouvez
absolument tout faire empaler au
mammalogie à partir du moment où vous
trouvez des dents et ce qui est
formidable c'est que les dents est en
fait des mailles c'est à dire étant déjà
à 90% de la pierre ni plus ni moi c'est
déjà 90% cristalliser les mayas que 10%
de tissus mous dans l'émail bas c'est
basiquement déjà de la roche kwassa
fossilise très très bien mais évidemment
la dent tribos phoenix n'est pas la
seule innovation des mammifères les
mammifères ils ont d'autres innovations
et notamment l'oreille moyenne alors
l'oreille moyenne on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler quand on parlera des
signes de l'évolution des synapses id
mais les eaux de l'oreille moyenne sont
complètement détachée de la mâchoire
inférieure chez les mammifères
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le sulky us
de meckel houleux la gouttière de meckel
donc c'est ce que vous voyez ici en
marron donc chez les synapses id on
avait plusieurs zoos à l'intérieur de la
mâchoire mais ces eaux se sont tous
réduits et se sont transformées en
espèces de 2 2 de globules gao se voilà
qui se trouve à l'arrière de la mâchoire
ici et ce gloubiboulga osseux il se
trouve dans ce qu'on appelle le sillon
ou la gouttière de meckel donc ce que
vous voyez en marron ici et chez les
mammifères
même si on trouve pas toujours le
globule gao se on trouve au moins le suc
us qui correspond à ce gloubiboulga
osseux et il se trouve que chez les
mammifères modernes bas il n'y a pas de
sucre us comme ça vous regarde et la
mâchoire il n'y a pas du tout de cette
trace de trucs marrants
par contre ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
c'est qu'en fait apparemment ça s'est
perdu de façon convergente les mots
notres m l'ont perdue d'un côté et les
teria l'ont perdu de l'autre
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant mais on
verra tout ça en détail l'évolution des
des os de la mâchoire
les mammifères ils ont aussi la capacité
de faire la promotion supination donc
pronation supination vous prenez votre
mal en droit vous la retourne et vous la
mettez à l'envers voilà vous êtes le
seul animal sur terre à arriver à faire
ça les reptiles les crocodiles les les
dinosaures n'étaient pas capables et
les amphibia n'en sont pas capables les
oiseaux n'en sont pas capables bref
seuls les mammifères sont capables de
faire ce mouvement de de retourner votre
main complètement parce que votre radio
c'est votre une nasse sont capables de
se croiser ce qui n'est pas le cas chez
les autres amniotes donc ça c'est
quelque chose de tout con pour nous mais
c'est formidable en réalité donc
évidemment beaucoup de mammifères ont
perdu ensuite seconde herman cette
capacité notamment ceux qui se sont
adaptés à la course donc comme les
carnivores et les herbivores donc
beaucoup de carnivores et de grands
herbivores comme les ongulés vont perdre
cette adaptation mais si vous regardez
les mammifères qui ont gardé le type
primitif et ben ils sont tous capables
de faire ça donc les écureuils par
exemple sont capables de le faire
ensuite dans la jambe parce qu'il n'ya
pas que le bras dans la vie dans la
jambe dans la jambe
vous avez le calcanéum donc l'os du
talon qui se trouve en dessous de
l'astragale c'est-à-dire l' os de la
cheville
chez les mammifères chez les mammifères
donc l'astragale est le seul os qui
s'articule avec le reste de la jambe
donc ici le tibia et la fibula donc
l'astragale est le seul os qui
s'articule avec la jambe ce n'est pas le
cas chez les reptiles chez les reptiles
l'astragale s'intitule avec le tibia le
calcanéum s'articule avec la fibula dont
vous avez une double articulation du
pied avec la jambe chais pas chez les
mammifères
vous avez que l'astragale donc ça c'est
aussi un caractère ostéo logique des
mammifères et bien sûr les mammifères
ont évolué ont acquis la lactation donc
la capacité de nourrir les petits avec
du lait donc chez les mots notres m ca
s'effectue par des glandes mammaires qui
sont dispersés sur un patch ventrale
donc en fait les mots notres m soientt
du lait mais n'ont pas vraiment de
deux grues enfin ils ont des glandes
mammaires mais ils n'ont pas vraiment de
deux mamelons dont qu'il soit juste du
lait qui est léchée par les petits mots
notres m par les petits bébés
ornithorynque là par exemple
d'ailleurs les mots notres elle nous
montre qu'en fait c'est bel et bien une
glande glandes sudoripares une glande à
sueur qui a évolué alors c'est un
mélange de glandes à sueur et de glande
assez bonne en fait donc le gras des
cheveux c'est ça le sébum et ben c'est
la mix entre la sueur et le sébum qui
forment le lait ouais je sais c'est
dégueulasse mais mais ça se suis très
bien embryon logiquement ça se voit très
bien et les mots notres aimons
typiquement les glandes mammaires des
mots notres m sont encore vont vraiment
très similaires à des glandes assurent
elles sont même encore associé à des
poêles et c'est aussi le cas chez les
marsupiaux chez les marsupiaux vous avez
un téton vous avez un mamelon
mais le mahb l'on a on est encore
associé à des poêles donc il ya guère
que celle et placentaires en fait qui a
pu l'association avec les poils et que
la glande mammaire est méconnaissable en
fait mais en réalité les glandes
sudoripares et à ces baumes sont les
glandes qui ont donné les les glandes
mammaires
donc on les appelle aussi les glandes
apocrines voilà c'est dégueulasse et à
propos de dégueulasse thé chez les mots
notres m bah on va parler des mots
notres m voilà ça fait déjà un bon
moment que ça dure donc si vous voulez
faire une petite pause à les y mettez
vous bien
prenez un petit café un petit coca
rafraîchissez-vous ça dépend s'il fait
chaud ou froid aujourd'hui et
voilà on va commencer maintenant à
parler donc du registre fossile de
chacun de ces grands groupes de
mammifères à savoir les mots notres m
les marsupiaux on terminera par les
placentaire et notamment la phylogénie
des placentaires donc pas encore tout de
suite le registre fossile des
placentaires parce que ça va vraiment
faire tout le reste
parce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on a
beau déjà on a un registre fossile des
placentaires qui est beaucoup plus riche
que pour les mots notres m ou les
marsupiaux
mais ça je vais vous en convaincre je
vais vous en convaincre dans les
prochaines slide donc c'est pour ça
qu'après on va passer beaucoup beaucoup
de temps sur les places inter alors
qu'on va basiquement parler des mots
notres m et des marsupiaux que
aujourd'hui on reparlera un petit peu
des marsupiaux pour l'épisode sur
l'amérique du sud parce qu'on verra qui
s'est passé des choses très
intéressantes en amérique du sud à
propos des marsupiaux
mais voilà puis bon de toute façon nous
ne sommes pas australien donc
globalement les mots notres m et les
marsupiaux sa forme pas la faune de
notre quotidien
donc ça nous intéresse moyennement les
mammifères qui nous entoure les chiens
les chats les les vaches les cochons
tout ça c'est du placentaire et les
humains évidemment sont aussi des
mammifères placentaires donc on n'est
pas vraiment en contact direct avec les
mots notres m au quotidien ni avec des
marsupiaux d'ailleurs et même le
registre fossile des marsupiaux dans le
reste du monde à part en australie et en
amérique du sud c'est assez maigrichon
mais on va voir ça en temps utile donc
c'est parti maintenant pour les mots
notres m
donc les mots notres m donc aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus que le
l'ornithorynque platypus en anglais et
l'échidné les deux équipes mais il ya
deux espèces dès qu'ils n'aident qui
survivent donc et tous les deux sont
appartiennent à des types écologiques
qui sont extrêmement différents mais
aussi extrêmement spécialisé donc
l'ornithorynque c'est un mammifère
aquatique piscivores ou pas piscivores
mais plutôt un vertébré bord bon ils
mangent aussi du poisson mais il mange
surtout des invertébrés donc des petits
des petits verres des larves des choses
comme ça hakuna matata et l'échidné
basséen c'est un fourmilier c'est un
mangeur de fourmis et de termites
donc voilà ces deux types écologique
extrêmement spécialisé donc de ce fait
les kinés et l'ornithorynque ont des
tronches
c'est ce qu'on appelle des mammifères à
tronche vous pouvez voir que le crâne de
l'échidné est complètement édenté à
cette espèce de long museau très faim
qu'on retrouve systématiquement chez les
ch et les fourmiliers pourquoi parce
qu'il a une très très longue langue donc
il ya ce trail très long museau très fin
il ya une très longue langue et il n'a
pas de dents parce que quand vous avez
une très longue langue qui s'accroche à
tout ce qui passe
y compris à de la terre et que vous
mettez à mastiquer de la terre avec vos
d'en bas vous finissez avec des abcès
gros comme n'importe quoi donc il ya une
très très forte sélection naturelle
contre la présence de dents chez les
mammifères fourmilier enfin adapté à au
mode de vie fourmilier donc on va voir
ça de façon récurrente chez les
mammifères et le l'ornithorynque alors
l'ornithorynque c'est intéressant parce
qu'il n'a pas de dents non plus mais par
contre il a des dents il a des dents de
lait donc il n'a pas de dents à l'âge
adulte mais il a des dents de lait et
un ornithorynque fossiles du nom de hope
dure aux dons est un ornithorynque géant
avec des grosses dents même à l'âge
adulte
et ça c'est très intéressant parce que
ça veut dire que c'est un phénomène
récent la perte des dents chez
l'ornithorynque aux bureaux dont
vivaient au pléistocène donc il ya moins
de deux millions d'années il à la
tronche d'un ornithorynque jusqu'ici les
géants et il a des dents est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est que grâce à aux
bureaux dont on sait à quoi
ressemblaient les dents dorny thorax et
du coup on peut être sûr qu'elles
étaient tribos fait nique et grâce à aux
bureaux dont on est capable de tracer la
morphologie des dans l'évolution de la
morphologie des dents depuis le type
tribos phoenix primitif donc ici vous
avez un des plus vieux fossile de mots
notres aime qu'on connaisse c'est ce
terreau peau dont du crétacé d'australie
donc pour une lignée qui serait apparu
au début du jurassique
c'est pas génial mais le registre
fossile des mots notres m indiquent
qu'ils n'ont jamais quitté l'australie
donc
donc déjà sa limite considérablement la
surface de recherche
quand on veut chercher du monodrame
fossiles et puis le registre fossile
australien pour ce qui est du mésozoïque
il est pas il n'est pas grandiose
grandiose
il ya des sites pas mal mais ce sont des
patchs en fait il est tres et des
patches donc il ya des sites qui
fournissent beaucoup de matériel mais
comme ils sont très limitées dans le
temps bah du coup ça aide pas donc voici
ce terreau peau dont c'est une mandibule
et on reconnaît donc on voit bien la
morphologie tribos phoenix de ses dents
ce qui est intéressant aussi avec ce
théropodes on sait que c'est un fossile
au palliser s'éteint c'est donc un faux
cils en pierres semi précieuses et ça
c'est quand même la classe
voilà quelques caractères typiques des
mots notres m il ya aussi un au cpie
publiques chez les mots notres m donc là
vous le voyez ici donc ça c'est le
pelvis enfin le bassin du coup à l'avant
du bassin vous voyez des petits aux épis
public
donc voilà on parle souvent des aux
marsupiaux chez les ch et les marsupiaux
du coup on parle d aux marsupiaux les
aux marsupiaux céder aux hippies public
ou prêts publics ou pré pubiens du coup
donc et des eaux est pris et puis
pubiens du coup ils sont pas typique des
marsupiaux en réalité ils sont présents
chez les mots notres m
et en réalité ils sont présents chez
énormément de malia forme du mésozoïque
les aurait pu bien et donc ça veut pas
donc vous entendrez souvent dire que les
aux marsupiaux servent à porter une
poche mais en fait non les mots notres m
n'ont pas de poche et il est très fort
probable que les eaux et puis épi
pubiens n'est jamais servi à porter de
poche
d'ailleurs quand on dissèque des
marsupiaux aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas
évident parce qu'il faut des balles
d'autorisation mais il ya des gens qui
l'ont fait par le passé donc on peut
encore se référer à leur description
mais quand on dissèque un marsupial la
poche et pas attachés aux os et puis
plus bien pas du tout il ya des muscles
abdominaux qui sont attachées là mais
ils ont rien à voir avec la poche
donc voila et autres caractère
intéressant les mots notres m
en tout cas chez les mâles ont une
espèce de pointe osseuse
à l'arrière deux
à l'arrière du talon donc ce qui
s'appelle un tard salle sports en
anglais donc ils ont une espèce de
pointe osseuse à l'arrière du talon sur
les pattes arrière et qu'il est qui est
empoisonnée chez le mâle ornithorynque
donc elle est ça c'est un caractère qui
fait enfin le venin le fait de même
d'avoir du venin c'est un caractère qui
fait vraiment beaucoup penser aux
reptiles
de manière générale et qu'on associe
rarement aux mammifères bien
qu'évidemment il y est quand même pas
mal d'espèces de mammifères comme le
soleil nos dons des caraïbes où les
certaines espèces de loris donc des
primates qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
venimeuse
mais quand même le fait d'être venimeux
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'on a
un qu'on veut associer plus volontiers
aux reptiles
donc voilà c'est la seule diapos que
j'aurai sur le registre fossile démarque
des mots notres aime parce que ben comme
j'ai dit en quand vous regardez ce
terreau peau dont vous avez quasiment un
quart du registre fossile et démarre des
mots notres m
donc voilà c'est un peu c'est un peu
triste mais il n'y a pas beaucoup
beaucoup de fossiles de mots ne traîne
et ils sont tous en australie évidemment
les mots notres m sont aussi connues
notamment les équipes mais ils sont
connus pour avoir quatre grands au pénis
donc ce qui vous montrent que le pénis
était autrefois une structure perd donc
voilà ça c'est le pénis c'est le pénis
de notre cher ami l'échidné avec ses
quatre grands maintenant on monte on
monte gentiment la phylogénie vers les
mammifères teria donc les teria alors
les mammifères teria se distingue des
mots notres m par plusieurs caractères
hausse théologique premièrement la lys
feno id donc la liste benno id c'est un
os de la boîte crânienne on en reparlera
chez les synodaux chez les synapses ide
en général donc chez les synapses id la
liste fait nos idées étaient quasiment
absents chez les sino dont on a un os
qui s'appelle le préfet nos idées par
dans les pipes perrigault id ou là je
fatigue les pipes terry gou ide qui est
tout petit et qui participent à la
constitution de la boîte crânienne et en
fait il ya une tendance à
l'agrandissement de la liste benno id
tout au long de la ligne et d'emma malia
forme et cet agrandissement culmine donc
chez les mammifères teria chez qui la
liste benno id est très largement l'os
dominant de la fin pas très largement
mais est un des autres dominant de la
boîte crânienne et 7 alice feno id
particulièrement chez les teria il est
plus grand que la partie de l'ofsp est
re qui participent à la boîte crânienne
donc cette partie de l'os pétrole qui
participent à la boîte crânienne c'est
une petite lame d'eau ce qui se trouve à
l'avant de l'os qui contient la cochlée
donc la cochlée l'oreille interne que
vous voyez ici sont entourés par un os
ce qui s'appelle le pétrole et se paie
tre il émet une petite lame à l'avant
qui participent à la boîte crânienne
c'est la pète rose al lami n'a et est
donc la liste des nommés dans cette
prend la place du pétrole littéralement
da petrosa la mine a fini par
disparaître chez les mammifères teria
autre caractère intéressant du pétrole
c'est la cochlée donc à l'intérieur du
pétrole la cochlée fait au moins un tour
et elle peut faire jusqu'à neuf tours
chez les mammifères teria mais il ya
toujours au moins un tour chez les
vaches et les mots notres m en fait la
cochlée juste en forme de l donc la
cochlée osseuse du moins la cochlée en
tissus mous est un peu différente mais
la cochlée osseuse
elle est juste en forme de l chez les
mots notres m
donc elle est un peu plus simple là vous
avez une coque l'est un peu plus
enroulée qui fait au moins un tour sur
elle même vous perdez les côtes sur
l'atlas donc l'atlas qui est le premier
os
enfin qui est la première vertèbre du
cou donc d'où son nom atlas comme le
héros grec qui portait le monde bombe à
l'atlas c'est la première vertèbre
celles qui portent le crâne et il n'y a
plus de côtes sur cet atlas donc ça ça
achève une tendance qu'on verra chez les
saynètes site qui est la différenciation
des différentes parties de la colonne
vertébrale chez les chez les reptiles
toutes les vertèbres ou presque sont les
mêmes toutes les vertèbres
se ressemblent du coup à la queue et
elles ont toutes des côtes et on va voir
qu'en fait les côtes vont être perdus
sur les vertèbres lombaires elles vont
s'agrandir sur les vertèbres thoraciques
et les vertèbres cervicales vont aussi
perdre leurs côtes
l'atlas étant l'ultime vertèbres
l'ultime vertèbres à perdre ses côtes
ce qui implique du coup que les mots
notre âme avec un atlas sur le avait des
vertèbres sur leur atlas tout petit
vertèbres mais ils les ont et
l'astragale donc on a parlé tout à
l'heure de l'astragale l' os de la
cheville donc qui porte qui portent
l'articulation avec la jambe et bien
développe ce qu'on appelle un coup
donc c'est une petite construction en
fait entre la phase articulaires qui
s'articule avec la jambe et la face
articulaires qui s'articule avec le
reste du pied maintenant vous avez cette
petite construction vous voyez là ici et
cette petite construction est typique
des mammifères teria donc ça ce sont les
caractères finalement qu'on retrouve à
la fois chez les marsupiaux mais aussi
chez les placentaire
non ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est que
beaucoup de gens pensent en fait que les
que les marsupiaux sont plus primitif
que les placentaire et que du coup on
devrait trouver le plus on devrait
trouver des marsupiaux avant les
placentaire dans le registre fossile
c'est une idée fausse il s'agit de deux
groupes frère donc qui sont autant
dériver l'un que l'autre est en réalité
est bien bien que les marsupiaux et
était dominant sur les placentaire au
mésozoïque parce que oui il ya aussi des
histoires de dominance entre les espèces
qui sont pas dominante
mais voilà les marsupiaux et étaient
très nombreux et très diversifiées au
mésozoïque ils ont pris une grande
claque à la crise crétacé paléogène même
et bien qu'ils aient été dominants et
bien c'est le premier mammifère teria
est un place est en fait un ami faire re
teria donc il est plus proche des
placentaires que des méta teria c'est à
dire les marsupiaux
après si vous voulez une petite
distinction
je vais utiliser le teria et meta teria
et de façon synonyme à placentaire et
marsupiaux respectivement mais en
réalité en fait les placentaire sont un
sous-groupe à l'intérieur des noeuds
teria donc il existe des hôtes et ria
qui ne sont pas des placentaires mais
ils sont quand même plus étroitement
apparenté au placentaire co marsupiaux
et donc les méta teria inclut les
marsupiaux et vous avez des méta teria
qui ne sont pas des marsupiaux mais qui
sont plus apparentes et aux marsupiaux
quot quot placentaire donc là par
exemple vous avez jura maya qui est le
tout premier retard ya donc ce n'est pas
un plat sa terre mais il est plus
étroitement apparenté au placentaire
qu'à n'importe quoi d'autre donc jura
maya qui nous vient du jurassique de
chine possède le seul et unique
caractère placentaire qu'on retrouve
chez absolument tous les places à terre
parce que les placentaire sont si
diversifiés que
que qu'en fait c'est très très dur de
trouver un caractère qui se retrouve
chez tous mais il ya ce caractère là au
moins et ce caractère qu'on retrouve
chez tous les hôtes herria pardon parler
placentaire et bien c'est la présence de
trois molaires une deux trois et une
prémolaires qui est mollahs reform c'est
à dire une prémolaires qui est plus
grosse que les autres prémolaires et
donc qui ressemble à une molaire donc
voilà une molaire deux molaires 3
molères et une 4e et une dernière
prémolaires donc il peut être la
quatrième ou la cinquième parce qu'à
l'époque les hôtes herria il avait 5 où
je pouvais avoir 5 prémolaires ça les
dérangeait pas donc une dernière
prémolaires qui est plus grosse en fait
que les autres prémolaires et ça se voit
aussi sur les dents du dessus donc ça
c'est les dents du dessus vous voyez
très bien la morphologie tribos phoenix
d'ailleurs une molaire de mahler 3
molères ici vous avez des prémolaires
est ici vous l'avez la dernière des des
prémolaires qui est très semblable à une
molaire donc c'est le seul caractère que
vous trouverez de façon constante chez
les hôtes et ria c'est pas d'autres
caractères que ça va évidemment il ya le
caractère qui est de donner naissance à
des petits qui sont autonomes mais ça
dans le registre fossile vous le verrez
par évidemment donc on n'utilise que le
caractère que ces caractères dentaire et
donc ça c'est en quoi ça diffère du coût
des méta terreau ya donc des marsupiaux
bas parce que les marsupiaux ils ont pas
non pas trois mais quatre molaires donc
pourquoi faire simple pourquoi faire
simple quand on est à placentaire au
lieu d'avoir quatre molaires les
placentaire en fait ils ont trois
molères et une dernière mme prémolaires
qui ressemble à une molaire voilà au
lieu d'avoir les quatre molaires des
mammifères meta teria donc chez les méta
teria chez les marsupiaux on va avoir
trois prémolaires et quatre molaires
alors que chez les hôtes et ria on va
avoir quatre ou cinq prémolaires et 3
molères évidemment la cinquième près
enfin là
la plupart des teria moderne ce qu'on va
voir romeo hausser nos héroïques ont
perdu la cinquième prémolaires donc il
ya que 4 prémolaires donc globalement
c'est le schéma inverse en fait des méta
teria vous avez trois molières 4
prémolaires celle et steria et vous avez
quatre molaires 3 prémolaires chez les
méta teria voilà c'est simple non alors
maintenant on divise
on plonge à l'intérieur des terres ya et
maintenant nous sommes chez les
marsupiaux donc on va regarder d'abord
la branche des marsupiaux pour ensuite
la laisser derrière nous et pouvoir se
focaliser uniquement sur la branche des
placentaires les marsupiaux donc et bien
les marsupiaux du clad meta teria à
l'intérieur duquel on trouve marsupial
ya et bien comme je voulais dit il se
caractérise par la présence de quatre
molaires et ils ont aussi une autre
particularité au niveau de leurs danses
et que en plus d'avoir quatre molaires
il n'ya en réalité que la dernière des
prémolaires qui se renouvelle donc la
dernière des prémolaires qui normalement
est la troisième prémolaires donc 1-2-3
prémolaires un deux trois quatre
molaires et vu qu' il n'y a que la
dernière des prêts molière qui se
renouvelle au lieu d'avoir toutes les
molaires en sous la forme de dents de
lait avant de les avoir sous forme
adulte et bien vu qu'il n'ya que la
dernière des prémolaires qui est
renouvelée et bien généralement vous
allez voir ce que vous voyez très bien
sûr ce diagramme c'est que la dernière
prémolaires en fait elle est beaucoup
moins usés que les molaires qui a
derrière elle donc
ça vous fait une quatrième prémolaires
très pointue à côté de molaire qui sont
déjà usées en fait but sur se voit très
bien sur la sur les sur les molaires
puisque les dés que speed notamment chez
les idées de films orphan on chez les
opossums sont très pointus bon
évidemment la diversité des marsupiaux
ne se limite pas qu'aux possum mais
l'opossum c'est vraiment le marsupial
typique un autre caractère important
chez les ch et les marsupiaux c'est
aussi le nombre d' assises yves donc
typiquement celle et placentaires on n'a
que 3 incisive alors que chez les
marsupiaux vous voyez là on en a cinq
1 2 3 4 5 sur la mâchoire supérieure et
sur la mâchoire inférieure on en a
quatre
donc donc c'est aussi un caractère qui
est important chez les ch et les
marsupiaux le nombre d' assises yves et
primitivement ils retiennent le nombre
de deux incisives primitive ils n'ont
pas réduit leur nombre d'incisives comme
c'est arrivé chez des placentaires enfin
un dernier caractère qui est pas
totalement unique aux marsupiaux mais
qui est quand même bien pratique si
jamais on n'est pas à l'aise avec les
danses éloge du gal donc le gall chez
les marsupiaux
il s'arrête pas au milieu de l'arcade
zygomatique comme chez la plupart des
pannes à sa terre il s'étend vers
l'arrière jusqu'à l'articulation de la
mâchoire qui se trouve ici
donc le jus galles participe à
l'articulation de la mâchoire et ça
c'est aussi un caractère qui est présent
chez tous les marsupiaux mais qu'on
retrouve très rarement par contre chez
les placentaire bon par contre on le
retrouve quelques fois par exemple chez
les dames en typiquement donc donc il
arrive que voilà ce caractère soit
présent chez les placentaire mais bon si
vous n'êtes pas à l'aise avec les
caractères dentaires ou si vous avez un
petit doute bon quand même quand votre
voix 5 incisive ya pas de doute à avoir
mais bon voilà si vous avez un petit
doute
vous pouvez toujours checker le jus
galets voir si ça colle aussi avec une
morphologie de marsupial donc le cpie
pubiens ou aux marsupial comme je les
dis n'est pas typique des marsupiaux
donc ça c'est pas possible donc ça c'est
bon c'est par contre il est absent chez
les placentaire c'est à noter encore que
il existe une théorie selon laquelle
l'os épi pubiens serait en fait
l'ancêtre entre guillemets de duba qu
l'homme donc mais ça on en reparlera à
l'épisode sur les carnivores si vous le
voulez bien
donc ici vous avez un exemple de
marsupial africa ce qui me permet de
vous dire que en fait bas les marsupiaux
était très largement dominant au crétacé
ils prennent une grosse claque à la
crise crétacé tertiaire mais ils
reprennent du poil de la bête
en début du cénozoïque est notamment
allé aux scènes où ils ont une deux
une distribution absolument mondiale
donc vous avez gars me dit terium et
en afrique donc ici dans l'eau lit dans
les hauts-seine d'égypte mais vous avez
aussi la sarig de cuvier donc la fameuse
le fameux opossum de montmartre que
cuvier avait avait préparé enfin la
légende dit que cuvier elle l'a préparé
devant la foule ébahie en prédisant
qu'il aurait eu ce marsupial et pouf il
a dégagé lors ce marsupial et voilà donc
la fameuse histoire de la saric de
cuvier balla saric de cuvier était un
marsupial c'était un petit topo somme de
l'oligocène de montmartre donc voilà les
marsupiaux étaient aussi présents en
france ils étaient présents absolument
partout et pas seulement en australie et
en amérique du sud comme ils le sont
aujourd'hui
donc cette réduction de cette
restriction finalement à l'amérique du
sud et à l'australie ce ne sont que des
refuges au final elle est reste un peu
maigrichon d'une dune d'une belle
diversité pas c'est quoi et comme comme
on a montré le gland le gland enfin le
gland à quatre extrémités finalement
entrer des mots notres m bah je vous
fais remarquer au passage que les
marsupiaux eux ils ont deux glands et
maintenant vous commencez à faire la
connexion avec le fait que les
placentaire n'ont plus qu'un gland donc
voilà on a cette tendance évolutive à la
réduction du nombre de gland bon c'est
pas pour autant qu'on n'a pas de gland
parmi les placentaire évidemment petit
jeu de mots petit jeu de mots jeux ça
fait longtemps que je parle maintenant
je commence à avoir de l'humour pourris
dont les marsupiaux ce qui est
intéressant c'est de regarder leur
diversité diversité qui n'a finalement
malgré leur réduction leur restriction
géographique leur diversité n'a rien à
envier à celle des placentaires donc on
a dollar bricole par exemple qu allah on
a dû de l'équivalent des écureuils
volants avec le le sugar glider on a dû
du rongeur avec les bandicoot oui
d'ailleurs crash bandicoot est inspiré
d'un vrai animal australien qui
s'appelle un bandicoot pour les vieux de
la vieille qui se rappelle de ce que
c'est que crash bandicoot évidemment
vous avez des taupes donc ici n'autorise
tesla taupe marsupial qui comme
certaines taupe européenne a des grosses
enfin comme certaines taupe placentaire
à de très grosses mains pour creuser et
avec des gros doigts en forme de pelles
et n'a pas d'yeux donc les yeux sont
complètement recouvert par de la
fourrure c'est ce qu'on retrouve par
exemple chez top doré africaine
vous avez qu'ironique thèse qui est le
seul marsupial aquatique
enfin semi aquatique pour le coup on va
reparler un petit peu évidemment le
kangourou alors le kangourou qui a une
tête de chameau sur un corps de deux
races auteurs géant donc là pour le coup
il n'y a pas d'équivalent chez les
places interne du kangourou
et donc qui renaît qu't'es j'aimerais
bien parler un petit peu de kinect est
donc peut-être certains d'entre vous se
sont demandé pourquoi il n'existait pas
de
de baleines marsupial et de
chauves-souris marsupial parce que c'est
vrai qu'au final vous avez ici une
diversité qui est alors si je mets cette
diapos là vous avez ici une diversité
finalement qui est très semblable à ce
qu'on rencontre chez les mammifères
placentaires donc à gauche vous avez les
mammifères placentaires et à droite vous
avez leurs équivalents marsupial donc
d'aider des trucs que j'ai passés par
exemple c'est le tasmanian wolf donc le
loup de tasmanie qui est l'équivalent
marsupial du marsupial du loup et vous
avez l'équivalent de des fours milliers
qui est le nom mme bhatt voilà bon vous
avez aussi l'échidné qui fait office de
defour milliers en australie mais c'est
pas un marsupial mais voilà l'idée c'est
que les marsupiaux finalement ils ont
fait en australie ce que les placentaire
ont fait partout ailleurs donc la
question c'est pourquoi il ya pas de
baleines ni deux
ni de chiroptères ni de chauves-souris
basse ça viendrait en fait peut-être de
leur développement
donc rappelez-vous les marsupiaux quand
ils sortent de leurs duc antilles et
quand la femelle marsupial accouche
elle accouche d'une petite larve qui
finalement n'a qu'une tête et des bras
voilà et le reste c'est vermiforme quoi
donc c'est une larve vraiment sauf que
les bras à l'intérieur des bras les eaux
sont extrêmement aussi fier vous pouviez
même voir qu'il y avait des petits
doigts et bien et je vous invite à
retourner vers ce passage-là de la vidéo
si vous voulez vérifier donc vous pouvez
même voir qu'il ya des petits doigts et
du coup ça veut dire que le marsupial
quand il naît doit avoir des bras avec
des doigts déjà différencié pour pouvoir
se traîner jusqu'à la poche
et ça ça mais une contrainte évolutive
énorme sur la forme que les bras peuvent
avoir chez les marsupiaux
ce qui fait que les bras ne peuvent pas
évoluer en l ou en nageoires comme ils
le peuvent
chez les placentaire du mois c'est une
des explications qui a été avancé et je
la trouve extrêmement élégante
c'est ce qu'on appelle typiquement une
contrainte développementale donc
l'évolution ne peut pas tout faire en
fait et des marsupiaux en sont victimes
mais c'est pour ça que kinect est
d'ailleurs si on revient c'est pour ça
que qu'ironique thèse vous voyez ici
il a les pieds palmés mais il n'a pas
les bras palmer à à un biais vous
remarqué bon évidemment vous avez un
contre exemple juste là qui est la taupe
marsupial qui a des gros doigts en forme
de pelle mais bon c'est quand même des
doigts ça reste des doigts et quand on
regarde un peu la phylogénie des
marsupial ce qu'il ya d'intéressant à
noter c'est que vous avez vous avez en
gros les marsupiaux qui sont en amérique
du sud qui sont bien distincts dans la
phylogénie des marsupiaux qu'on trouve
en australie est apparemment en fait les
groupes qui sont en australie sont les
ancêtres fallait l'ancêtre commun des
marsupiaux aux australiens et au silence
être finalement des marsupiaux
australien non pardon
l'ancêtre commun des marsupiaux
sud-américain est aussi l'ancêtre des
marsupiaux australiens ce qui voudrait
dire qu'il y aurait une
dispersion une dispersion peut-être à
partir de l'amérique du sud mais mais
mais mais ce scénario est uniquement
basée sur les marsupiaux moderne
rappelez-vous les marsupiaux avait une
distribution mondiale donc peut-être que
c'est en fait les marsupiaux qui était
présent à travers le monde et finalement
enfin bref les marsupiaux était présent
à travers le monde
allez hossein à l'oligocène jusqu'au mis
en scène et en fait ceux qui ont survécu
peut-être que c'est juste un coup de bol
si si finalement ils tous les bases
hausse ont survécu que en amérique du
sud et que tous les dérivés n'ont
survécu qu en australie mais bon c'est
plus probable quand même que l'ancêtre
commun de tous les marsupiaux
australiens soit arrivé enfin soit
arrivé en une fois en fait et pas en
plusieurs vagues du mois c'est ce
qu'indique la phylogénie des plats sains
des marsupiaux moderne
alors évidemment on ne peut pas parler
de la diversité des marsupiaux sans
parler de ce qui s'est passé en amérique
du sud et notamment en matière de
carnivores et donc c'est le moment de
parler death par aso dont tu ou des
bornes une idée donc les bords y ait une
idée étant les plus connus despars aso
dont tu
c'est à dire les mamies les marsupiaux
sud-américain carnivore le plus connu
d'entre eux étant évidemment tilak au
smi lui ce que vous voyez ici le fameux
kangourou à dents de sabre
parce que je vois pas d'autre moyen de
17 animal qu'en disant que c'est encore
pire c'est un koala dents de sabre là
cela c'est vraiment choquant mais en
réalité il n'est pas directement
apparentés ou kangourou quoi là c'est
plus un opossum à dents de sabre
qu'autre chose donc il se distingue du
du félin à dents de sabre donc dû
placentaire à dents de sabre si vous
préférez de par plusieurs caractères
déjà la taille du cerveau qui est très
petite comparée à celle du félin donc ça
c'est c'est plutôt un caractère de comme
je disais d'opossum les opossums ont un
cerveau très petit comparé aux places
inter moyens donc voilà c'est ça se
reflète celle ci la qos minus les dents
se prolonge très loin à l'intérieur du
crâne
comme vous pouvez voir les dents de
sabre se prolonge très loin ce qui crée
ses bosses en fait sur le dessus que le
smilodon donc le le dents de sabre
placentaire n'a pas et il y à ces
espèces de fourreaux sur la mandibule
pareil que le smilodon n'a pas mais on
verra qu'il ya certes un félin à dents
de sabre qui en avait mais jamais aussi
développée que celle eux que chez le ti
la qos minus et le thi lac aux 1000 us a
typiquement un crâne de marsupial un
autre caractère aussi oui c'est la part
dont la barre post orbitaire que vous
voyez ici
cette barque post orbitaire le ski
ferment l'orbité qui donne alors bits
cette forme bien ronde est absente chez
les félins à dents de sabre alors d'une
vous pouvez voir ici sur l'arcade
zygomatique de tila cosmi luce la future
entre le jus galles et le score aux
halles et vous pouvez voir que le jus
galles à une petite languette ici qui se
projette jusqu'à l'articulation de la
mâchoire et ceci est exactement comme
l'opossum donc c'est un caractère
typique de
de meta terriens de marsupial et vous
pouvez compter aussi le nombre de mots
l'air il y à une deux trois quatre dents
molères et après vous avez une réduction
du nombre de prémolaires parce que c'est
un carnivore et que les carnivores n'ont
pas besoin de prémolaires mais vous
voyez une deux trois quatre dents
molaires bien distinctes comme tout bon
marsupial qui se respecte shetty la qos
milus donc le compte est bon on a bien
tous les caractères d'un marsupial chez
ce bon il a co ce minus c'est donc un
exemple flagrant de convergence
évolutive avec les mammifères avec
l'ailé félin à dents de sabre
il faut bien se représenter cette idée
là c'est que tila cosmi l'us aid n'est
pas un félin à dents de sabre c'est
vraiment un marsupial à dents de sabre
donc un opossum à dents de sabre et vous
pouvez voir la tille aquos minutes c'est
une image elle est trop choupinou cette
image vous pouvez voir le petit il a co
ce minus dans la poche de sa mère ici
avec ses petites culottes
alors ça c'est probablement faux puisque
je voulais dit tout à l'heure la seule
dent de lait que possèdent les
marsupiaux c'est la quatrième
prémolaires donc pardon c'est la
troisième prémolaires donc je sais la
dernière prémolaires quoi qu'il arrive
donc la seule mme dents de lait qu'on
les marsupiaux c'est la dernière
prémolaires donc ils peuvent pas avoir
des petites canine de l'est comme sales
et les bêtises un cos minutes mais bref
c'est quand même trop choupinou et ça ça
vous illustre quand même bien l'idée que
voilà faux-pas faut pas se représenter
at-il aquos minutes du tout comme un
mammifère placentaire et un autre groupe
qui à mon sens il ne faut pas négliger
chez les ch et les marsupiaux mais cette
fois chez les marsupiaux australien donc
on s'en va de l'amérique du sud
c'est le groupe des dix proto d'hondt
alors je sais bien qu'il ya d'autres
groupes qu'il faut pas négliger chez les
marsupiaux notamment lady delphi mort
femmes et lady delphi morfales c'est
vraiment les opossums c'est les
marsupiaux qu'on retrouve partout
en tout cas pendant les eaux saines et
le lit gaussen ils sont absolument
partout donc c'est le marsupial de base
l'opossum donc je vous en ai déjà parlé
rien qu'en parlant des marsupiaux de
base quoi donc là on voit les groupes
qui sont spécialisés donc on a vu les
carnivores spécialistes maintenant on va
voir les herbivores spécialistes que
sont les dix proto dont tu donc lady
bretons dont ils sont fortement adapté à
un régime herbivores et du coup ils ont
des dents qui sont lofo dont tu donc
voilà premier exemple de dans l'eau faut
donc avec les deux gros love que vous
voyez là et des dents qui peuvent être
donc bu naulleau faut donc s'ils sont
follivores ou ips solofo d'onde s'ils
sont herbivores comme les kangourous
donc herbivores dans le sens grammy
nivore et lady proto dompter bien ils
ont plusieurs caractères dérivés en plus
de cette dentition below fondante
ils ont d énormes incisive notamment les
incisives du dessous vous en avez une
seule donc vous n'avez qu'une seule
paire d'incisives au lieu de 4 incisive
sur les dents du bas donc vous voyez ça
fait un peu comme des rongeurs et elles
sont dites pro comme bolt donc pro comme
band ça veut dire pro clive incliné vers
l'avant
donc c'est un petit peu c'est exactement
ce que vous voyez là quoi des dents du
dessous incliné vers l'avant donc ça
fait un peu comme une pelle en fait des
ils ont les incisives inférieur comme
des pelles et ça fait pas mal ressembler
à d'ailleurs à des rongeurs et surtout
les dix proto d'hondt et notamment c'est
notamment visible chez les mégapoles que
sont les kangourous lady proto d'hondt
ont des pieds vachement bizarre lady
proto donne donc on a pied extrêmement
particulier donc ce que vous pouvez voir
ici
ils ont les doigts 2 et 3 qui sont très
réduits le doigt numéro un est
complètement absent donc l'orteil ah si
vous préférez le pouce de leurs taye est
complètement perdu le
doit 2 et 3 les orteils 2 et 3 sont
réduits et l'orteil 3 4 et 5
finalement ce sont les seuls orteil qui
sont très développés donc ça se voit
très bien ici sur le pied du kangourou
donc
là les kangourous finalement saute sur
le doigt 4 et 5 est principalement sur
le doigt 4 mais ça se voit aussi par
exemple chez un autre dit proto d'onde
que qu'est le koala donc si vous
regardez le pied du koala vous avez les
doigts 4 et 5 qui sont très développés
et les doigts 2 et 3 qui sont fusionnés
finalement et pas deux doigts 1
et c'est aussi le cas chez le groupe bat
enfin bref le koala kangourou combattre
ce sont les dix proton sont les plus
typiques on va dire mais vous avez
évidemment un registre fossile des dix
proto d'hondt qui est absolument
formidable lady proton quand même qu'ils
ne tiennent leur nom de 10 proto donc
que vous voyez ici dont vous pouvez voir
ici les incisives pro clive promis
proéminente sur la mâchoire et la
morphologie below faut donc très typique
des dix proto donc dit proto nom qui est
ni plus ni moins qu'un bon bah de géant
au final et j'ai dit tout à l'heure que
les dix pros taux longs étaient
herbivores
ce n'est pas toujours le cas il y a eu
lundi proto nom de carnivores parce que
on est en australie et donc la niche des
carnivores est vacante et elle est
occupée aussi par lesdits proto d'hondt
au pléistocène du moins et au
pléistocène vous avez donc tu il a collé
au que voici qui avaient des dix proto
non alors il a perdu là
il a perdu la morphologie below fondante
parce que il a sept îles à ces espèces
dedans carnivores en forme de lame un
trait typique des carnivores mais par
contre il a toujours la première paire
d'incisives du la mâchoire inférieure
qui est pro clive donc la signature
finalement desdits proto l'ontt et de
sons de ses ancêtres du poteau dont tu
alors tu il a collé au comme dit proto
dons et de nombreuses autres espèces
sont très représentatifs de ce qu'on
appelle la mégafaune australienne du
pléistocène donc c'est une faune c'est
une mégafaune qui a finalement régner
sur l'australie et dans laquelle on
trouve comme je disais à 10 proto ledit
proto dont le tilt accolé au des
kangourous géant on trouvait aussi des
oiseaux géants
proche du moa et ont trouvé mes galas
n'ya donc l'équivalent du varan de
komodo mais encore plus gros des fois
que vous vous demandiez si un varan de
komodo ce n'était pas déjà assez gros et
toute cette faune finalement toute cette
mégafaune va disparaître à l'arrivée
d'une espèces migrantes cette espèce
c'est l'homme c'est l'homme est alors là
là où il faut pas non plus faire
d'erreurs c'est que c'est pas la colonie
zen c'est pas de la colonisation dont je
parle ce n'est pas l'arrivée des
européens c'est l'arrivée des ancêtres
des aborigènes donc les ancêtres des
aborigènes déjà ont eu un tableau de
chasse que vous pouvez voir ici qui est
quand même assez assez catastrophique 1
ils ont ils ont quand même leur arrivée
a quand même fou tout le bordel si je
puis dire
donc c'est pas c'est pas l'arrivée de dd
colons britanniques dans les années 1800
non je parle assez les ancêtres des
natifs au str australien donc voilà et
dans le cas de l'australie donc on sait
qu'il ya eu aussi un changement
climatique qui arrivait au même moment
ben on le sait parce que déjà l'homme a
pu arriver alors que du moins à cette
époque là on pense qu'il ya cinquante
mille ans il n'était pas encore capables
de construire des bateaux donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya forcément eu un une
descente au niveau de la mer et donc du
coup un refroidissement
donc il ya quand même eu il ya il ya eu
d'autres facteurs que l'arrivée de
l'homme aussi qui ont joué et qui
alimente du coup un certain débat sur la
responsabilité de l'homme dans cette
extinction
ce qui nous amène au placentaire donc
avec cette grande extinction de la
mégafaune australienne qui n'est
finalement que le prémice de
l'extinction tout court des marsupiaux
nous arrivons aux mammifères
placentaires le groupe le plus
diversifié de mammifères modernes
diversifiés tant en termes du nombre
d'espèces puisqu'il ya beaucoup plus de
mammifères placentaires que deux
marsupiaux de mots notres m
mais aussi diversifié en termes
deco morphologie puisque nous l'avons
dit tout à l'heure il y a des baleines
placentaire et il y a des éléphants
placentaire et il ya des des
chauves-souris placentaire que les
marsupiaux n'ont pas donc donc une très
grande diversité une très grande
diversité de taille aussi bref et les
placentaire vont connaître
la même histoire que les marsupiaux mais
en quatre fois mais ça on va le voir on
va le voir plus tard ce qu'il ya
d'important déjà savoir à propos des
placentaires c'est que alors d'après le
registre fossile les aux terriens
apparaissent au jurassique mêlée
placentaire n'apparaissent que à la
toute fin du crétacé il ya à peu près 70
millions d'années les premiers
mammifères qu'on peut appeler des
placentaires donc il s'agit de protons
bull at home et de purgatorio us
respectivement attribués alors
respectivement rattaché proton gül atom
il pourrait être rattachée aux puristes
d'actifs c'est-à-dire aux chevaux et
procure gâteau rieuse pourrait être
rattachée aux primates on en reparlera
mais bref voilà proton gül atom et
purgatorio ce sont les tout premiers
tout première espèce enfin genre qu'on
pourrait appeler placentaire et il se
trouve qu'ils apparaissent à la toute
fin du crétacé donc ce qui veut dire que
on a définitivement une origine
mésozoïque des placentaires mais alors
là où c'est fort c'est que d'après les
phylogénie moléculaire c'est à dire
d'après les fils au génie basé sur l'adn
et les protéines et c'est ce que vous
voyez là votre écran bah en fait c'est
pas seulement les placentaire qui
apparaît ce trait au mésozoïque mais
bien tous les grands ordres de
placentaire donc ici vous voyez de là
toutes ses lignes qui connecte les
espèces modernes
il y en a beaucoup d'entre elles qui
s'étendent vous voyez fou ce jusqu au
crétacé voyez là donc ça là ça voudrait
dire que la lignée des écureuils par
exemple squirell veut dire écureuils
c'est à dire que la lignée des écureuils
là elle s'étend jusqu'aux crétacé là si
vous prenez armadillo donc le tattoo le
tattoo il aurait aussi s'aligner qui
s'étend jusqu'aux crétacé on devrait
trouver des tas tour crétacé si on en
suisse est phylogénie si on suit cette
phylogénie on devrait trouver des
aardvark donc des oryctérope au crétacé
on devrait trouver des éléphants
quasiment jusque jusqu'au début du
paléocène et ça pour autant qu'on sache
on en a pas voilà est le seul cas où ça
colle à peu près c'est avec justement
les primates donc si on suit la lignée
des primates ici et qu'on remonte jusque
là là effectivement on a du primate au
crétacé mai donc on a pu regagner ce qui
effectivement de la toute fin du crétacé
70 millions d'années mais là là là si
vous suivez cette ligne là ici où l'on
devrait trouver des primates jusqu'à 80
millions d'années voire voire plus que
ça voyez là si on prend là toute base de
cette branche de la branche qui mène aux
primates on a presque 90 millions
d'années donc il ya de grosses
incohérences en fait entre le ce que
nous disent les fils au génie
moléculaires basés sur l'horloge
moléculaire c'est à dire que en comptant
le nombre finalement ce que font les
généticiens avec l'horloge moléculaire
c'est qu'il compte le nombre de
mutations qui a eu lieu qui ont eu lieu
pendant la divergence des espèces et en
modélisant finalement là le temps qu'il
faut entre chaque mutation
il reconstitue la longueur de ses
branches donc la longueur de chaque
ligne et qui les amène à une date donc
date qui est systématiquement donc si
j'en parle si j'en parle c'est parce que
c'est parce qu'on a passé le stade en
fait où il s'agirait d'un artefact de
calcul s'il ya aussi ça parce
qu'évidemment j'anticipe vos questions
aussi c'est que
évidemment de la manière où je suis en
train de l'expliquer je l'expliquent
d'une façon extrêmement simplifier le
fonctionnement de l'horloge moléculaire
et du coup ce que vous êtes en train de
vous dire c'est que bah oui le temps
enfin je veux dire on peut pas savoir
combien de temps il ya entre de mutation
c'est un défaut de modélisation oui mais
si j'en parle c'est bel et bien parce
qu'on a passé le stade où les erreurs de
où les erreurs de modélisation en fait
sont la source du problème
on est arrivé à un stade où on finit par
se demander soit il ya un gros truc
qu'on comprend pas à propos des
mutations de l'adn est évidemment les
généticiens vous diront que ce n'est pas
le cas soit il ya un gros truc qu'on
comprend pas au niveau du registre
fossile et s'il ya bien un truc qu'on
sait à propos du registre fossile c'est
qu'il est pas complet voilà donc les
généticiens rejette la faute sur les
paléontologues les paléontologues
rejette la faute sur les modèles
utilisés par les généticiens mais au
final il y a un problème il ya un
problème quelque part et c'est
certainement le débat fait rage mais
c'est certainement une cause partagée
c'est à dire que oui les modèles peuvent
être améliorés mais oui va peut-être
falloir envisager de détendre certaines
de nos lignes et dans le crétacé
on a dénoté rien on a beaucoup beaucoup
de terriens dans le crétacé notamment en
mongolie par exemple la mongolie est
très connue évidemment pour ces proto
ceratops essais etc velociraptor mais
évidemment s'il y'avait proto ceratops
velociraptor il y avait aussi d'autres
animaux y compris des deux terriens donc
il y avait des eaux therrien au crétacé
c'est pas le problème le problème c'est
que pour autant qu'on sache ils ne sont
pas rattachées au placentaire et la
vérité c'est que peut-être que si du
coup voilà donc ce que ce que nous
suggère les généticiens c'est qu'en fait
elle peut-être que si en fait peut-être
que ces deux terriens ne sont pas
seulement des aux terriens peut-être que
ce sont des aux terriens placentaire
mais voilà c'était pour vous tenir au
courant de ce débat il n'est pas fini il
est très loin d'être finie
bon bah on attend les développements les
futurs développements
voilà en tout cas on a tellement beau
registre fossile des placentaires en
fait qu'on est capable de reconstituer
un portrait robot de l'ancêtre commun
donc ce que je vous montre là c'est pas
vraiment un fossile qui a été retrouvé
c'est juste le portrait robot de
l'ancêtre en commun qu'on peut
reconstruire à partir de ce qu'on sait
justement des eaux terriens du crétacé
des placentaires du paléocène et des
inférences phylogénétique qui les relie
en fait donc à partir de ça on peut dire
que l'ancêtre commun des placentaires en
fait c'est ça faisait partie justement
de ces animaux qui étaient pas très qui
son papa qui sont pas partis très loin
du morphotype de base en fait des mains
malia forme donc vous rappelez de
morganucodon petit musaraigne
insectivores et nocturne bon bah là on
est typiquement là dessus on est sûr de
la petite musaraigne insectivores et
nocturne pour l'ancêtre commun des
placentaires donc un ancêtre commun
finalement qui a pas beaucoup bougé de
l'ancêtre commun des maliens forme donc
donc un animal qui ne fait que quelques
grammes avec un cerveau relativement
simple mais des eaux de l'oreille
moyenne complètement détachée de la
mâchoire et qui forment déjà les trois
aussi kull donc les trilles et l'enclume
et le marteau ou le marteau et l'enclume
l'étrier si vous préférez dans l'autre
sens le tympan évidemment et est
évidemment mon caractère préféré le
pénis qui cette fois n'est pas bifide ou
n'a pas quatre extrémités mais le gland
il n'y a qu'un seul blanc voilà donc ça
y est le pénis à un gland bravo les
placentaire et évidemment la dentition
évidemment donc un deux trois mots l'air
et une 4e et une 4e prémolaires qui est
ressemble aux molaires mais n'est pas
une molaire voilà la différence entre
molaires et prémolaires c'est le nombre
de racine les prémolaires les
prémolaires en primitivement une seule
racines ça peut évoluer chez les
placentaire ci notamment chez les
herbivores
mais primitivement les prémolaires ont
une racine et les mollets ronde aux
racines en fait donc c'est ça la
différence entre prémolaires et molaires
donc si vous avez une dent mollahs
reform avec une seule racines c'est une
prémolaires mollahs reform donc voila
voila est évident et le nombre
d'incidents est aussi une de 3 incisive
contrairement aux quatre incisive
inférieur chez les
chez les marsupiaux et 5 incisives
supérieures aussi chez les marsupiaux là
vous avez trois incisive en autres
incisive en bas nous y voilà donc chez
les placentaire donc comme je le disais
le plus banal des terriens se jura maya
mais c'est pas le seul qu'on est au
mésozoïque on a aussi et aux mayas qui
était le plus connu qui est probablement
toujours le plus connu par rapport à
jura maya
mais bon ils sont très similaires que ce
sont de petites musaraigne insectivores
n'ya pas il n'ya pas à tortiller et
maintenant on va attaquer la phylogénie
des mammifères alors là c'est le moment
où j'ai vite mes étudiants et donc je
vous invite vous aussi aller prendre un
café à respirer un grand coup aller
prendre l'air
fait une petite pause allait manger les
faire quelque chose parce que là là on
va vraiment commencer à discuter là ça
va devenir sérieux ok au cas où vous
trouviez ça facile jusqu'à présent
évidemment mais si vous trouviez ça
facile et que ça commence à devenir
chiant pour vous là c'est bon il va
falloir commencer à s'accrocher là on
commence à avoir du challenge parce
qu'on attaque la phylogénie des
placentaires et j'espère vous convaincre
à l'issue de cette de cette dernière
partie de ce premier cours que
sérieusement faut s'arrêter dessus je
veux dire c'est pas pour rien qu'on fait
qu'on fait tant de enfin que c'est pas
pour rien que je vais faire cette course
sur les placentaire et uniquement sur
les placentaire et que j'ai seulement
fait un quart de cours pour les
marsupiaux c'est parce que l'histoire
des placentaires c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment la galère
et donc donc voilà je sais que je vous
montre en fait donc on est reparti voilà
on s'y remet donc là ce que je vous
montre c'est la phylogénie des
mammifères telle qu'on la pensait encore
dans les années 90 et au début des
années 2000 est telle que certains
l'envisagent encore aujourd'hui les
vieux de la vieille le visage encore
comme ça les ceux qui ont de la
bouteille et puis ça c'est la façon dont
les gens qui suivent l'actualité
envisage désormais la phylogénie des
mammifères donc essayé la vision
finalement qu'on rapportait les
généticiens l'évolution des mammifères
donc alors déjà de ce point de vue là
des déjà à dd maintenant j'ai envie de
dire j'ai envie de dire que je suis pour
cette phylogénie là pour la simple et
bonne raison que encore une fois au
début on avait quelques protéines ont
après on a eu que quelques gênes après
on a eu plusieurs gènes après on a eu
des génomes entiers et après on a eu des
génomes entiers pour des milliers
d'espèces et systématiquement c'est cet
arbre là qui revient jamais celui là
donc quand on regarde des génomes
entiers sur des milliers d'espèces et
qu'on retrouve toujours le même résultat
est que ce résultat c'est celui-là ça
veut dire que c'est ce résultat le bon
voilà donc même si au niveau de la
morphologie ce pas du tout la même chose
qu'on retrouve force est de constater
que c'est les jeunes qui gagne est pas
la morphologie donc cet arbre ne fait
absolument aucun sens en terme de
morphologie et vous allez le voir au fur
et à mesure des diapos que je vais vous
montrer mais c'est quand même celui là
qui est le bon je veux dire faut arrêter
de tergiverser sur kick a raison qui a
tort c'est cet arbre là qui est le bon
point c'est tout et c'est la morphologie
qui a tort donc avant on avait un modèle
de fil au génie basé sur la morphologie
parce qu'on avait que ça on n'avait pas
les gènes
donc on avait les xena retour à la base
donc les xena retracer les
mammifère sud américain et puis après on
avait une séparation qui était basé sur
le régime alimentaire donc vous aviez
les insectivores vous aviez les rongeurs
et les lagons mort donc des herbivores
vous aviez les
et les primates et autres espèces
arboricoles et frugivores insectivores
et puis vous aviez les animaux dont le
régime alimentaire est à base de
protéines donc les carnivores et les
folies dote les folies lot célé pangolin
donc cdd fourmilier il ya certaines
phylogénie qui groupait les folies dote
avec les dizaines artres parce qu'ils se
ressemblent beaucoup il ya des voix là
tu vous pensez fourmilier vous pensez
fourmilier sud-américain donc gène
artres bon alors certaines fois il était
avec les carnivores certaines fois il
était avec selena
mais voilà mais ça faisait toujours sans
ce niveau de la morphologie à quoi qu'il
arrive c'est soit vous les métiers avec
les mangeurs de protéines animales soit
vous les métiers avec les autres trucs
qui est qu'ils n'avaient pas dedans et
qui était fourmilier et vous aviez les
herbivores qu'on appelait les ongulés
voilà donc herbivores carnivores
arboricole petit herbivore insectivores
et trucs sud américain un peu barrés y
voilà et évidemment à la base les
marsupiaux les mots notres m qui ne sont
pas des placentaires évidemment c'est
c'est pour enraciner la phylogénie donc
vous avez une phylogénique et niveau
morphologie à faisait tout à fait sens
et est tout à fait logique on va dire
bon à part un par quelques petits points
de détails par ci par là qui étaient
débattus les folies dot comme je le
disais les cétacés on les mettait pas
toujours parmi les ongulés mais bon
voilà il se balader par la laitue bully
dante et c'est pareil donc le
l'oryctérope c'est aussi un fourmilier
donc de temps en temps il partait du
côté des xxii hainard mais voilà
globalement on avait une image assez
claire de la phylogénie mammifères et
pouf d'un seul coup les généticiens nous
disent que c'est pas ça du tout voilà
donc les insectivores complètement
explosé les ongulés complètement
exploser donc mais bref on va voir tout
ça dans le détail
et comme je le disais c'est la
phylogénie des généticiens que je vais
suivre parce que ils ont juste quand on
parle de génétique et de génomes
complets on parle de millions de paires
de bases donc deux millions de
caractères la plus grosse phylogénie
morphologiques qui ait jamais été fait
elle avait tout au plus quinze mille
caractères donc voilà on parle de
millions de caractères contre au maximum
quinze mille caractères tu peux pas test
c'est les généticiens qui ont raison et
leurs modèles
on utilise encore aussi la morphologie
donc le maximum de parcimonie en
cladistique basé sur la morphologie
les généticiens maintenant ils en sont à
utiliser du bayer ziadé me des approches
probabilistic je vais dire un têtu tu
peux pas test tu peux pas test la
génétique voilà donc c'est les
généticiens qui ont raison et et
finalement on va voir que c'est pas
c'est pas si con que ça en fait leur
arbre oui il est pas si con que ça donc
à l'intérieur des mammifères aujourd'hui
on distingue trois super ordre donc le
super ordre en rouge le super ordre vers
le super ordre bleus le super ordre
jaune et le super ordre rouge s'appelle
les afro teria car il est composé de
mammifères soit qu'ils ne vivent qu'en
afrique soit qu'ils ont un registre
fossile qui pointent clairement vers
l'afrique comme étant leur centre
d'origine donc à l'intérieur de ces
affreux terre on retrouve les temps
récit des donc les temps récit des dons
on retrouve des représentants à
madagascar et en afrique du sud
ils sont des petit insectivore les
crises au chloride est donc qui sont les
tops dorée du kalahari et uniquement du
kalahari donc c'est là où je vous dis
que c'est strictement africain
donc ça veut dire que l'étau doré toute
ressemblance qu'elle faisait avec les
taupes qu'on connaît en europe sont ne
sont pas des taupes
en fait ces voix là on appelle ça des
taupes doré parce que ça ressemble à des
tops ce ne sont pas des taupes ce truc
est plus proche parent de l'éléphant
qu'il ne l'ait de la taupe et c'est là
que c'est beau c'est ça que c'est beau
donc les crises au chloride et les
maquereaux c'est l'idée qu'on appelle
aussi les rats à trompe qui ne sont pas
des rats mais qui est dont la trompe
n'est pas homologue à celle des
éléphants c'est une convergence
évolutive ce qui est bien dommage parce
que effectivement les rats à trompe sont
plus reliés aux éléphants cas
n'importe quelles autres espèces de rats
les oryctérope sont aussi des afro
terriens les sirénia et les irak aux ide
alors parmi donc tous ces animaux vous
voyez ils ont des types écologique est
extrêmement différent je veux dire vous
avez basiquement ce qui est probablement
l'un des plus petits mammifères du monde
donc les taupes doré avec probablement
ce qui est le plus grand mammifère
terrestre du monde les proboscidiens
donc des animaux de plusieurs tonnes des
animaux de quelques grammes des
insectivores des des fournisseurs d donc
ça c'est un fourmilier du coup tu sais
ça fait partie de ces animaux qui se
nourrissent exclusivement de termites et
de fourmies
vous avez des mammifères semis des
mammifères aquatiques parlons pas
semi-aquatique complètement aquatique
qui est qui plus est le seul mammifère
herbivore aquatique
vous avez un truc qui ressemble à des
rongeurs vous avez un autre truc qui
ressemblent à des petits rongeurs
sauteurs donc bref bas c'est le merdier
c'est le merdier donc là et le registre
fossile nous aide pas beaucoup de ce
point de vue du point de vue de
comprendre d'où viennent tous ces
animaux à quoi ressemblait l'ancêtre
commun finalement de tout ça parce que
c'est ça la grosse question qu'on se
pose ça veut dire que tous ces types
écologique différents ont évolué à
partir d'un ancêtre commun et là ce que
vous voyez en gris en fait c'est sont
les groupes pour lesquels le registre
fossile ne nous aide
absolument pas parce que le registre
fossile en fait et pas assez complet et
que quand ces animaux apparaissent pour
la première fois dans le registre
fossile
il ressemble déjà aux espèces modernes
dans les grandes lignes
dans le détail évidemment ils sont un
peu différents mais dans les grandes
lignes les premiers les premiers
oryctérope sont déjà des fourmis lier
les premières tombes dorés sont déjà des
taupes
enfin comme des taupes les premiers
temps récit des sont déjà des insectes
yvan les premiers macro ses idées sont
déjà des petites bestioles qui sautait
donc voilà donc il que les proboscidiens
les irak aux idées les siréniens qui ont
vraiment subi des changements macro
évolutif conséquent qu'on peut suivre à
partir du registre fossile ce qui veut
pas dire qu'ils sont pas arrivés là
pour ces quatre groupes là mais ça veut
dire qu'on l'a
on les a pas bien documenté jusqu'à
présent est en fait qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé bien il se trouve que l'ancêtre
commun un ancêtre commun des afro terre
est arrivé en afrique quelque part au
crétacé ou bien tout simplement un
groupe de mammifères a évolué et s'est
retrouvé isolé en afrique au crétacé
parce que l'afrique au crétacé s'est
séparé finalement du reste du monde
comme je le disais il n'y avait pas de
calottes polaires à l'époque il faisait
très chaud et donc le niveau des mers
était très haut et du coup l'afrique
était vous voyez complètement séparées
et de l'eurasie et de l'amérique du sud
alors il ya un ancêtre commun qui arrive
et on sait pas trop d'où ou qui étaient
déjà là et comme il s'est retrouvé isolé
en afrique bas il nous a fait une nous a
fait une marsupial si vous préférez si
vous voulez nous a fait exactement ce
que les marsupiaux fait en australie
c'est à dire qu'il s'est mis à faire son
petit job dans son coin et il a évolué
dans tous les types écologiques
possibles et imaginables de l'herbivore
géant aux mammifères semi aquatique au
petit insectivore à la taupe et cetera
donc il s'est mis à tout faire tout seul
à part carnivores voilà si vous
remarquez les mammifères les afro terre
le seul truc qu'ils ont pas fait ces
carnivores le truc le plus carnivore que
vous ayez scellé
oryctérope encore que dans le registre
fossile il ya du débat sur un groupe qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle les ptolémées
idée qui aurait pu être insectivores un
carnivore
mais voilà donc isolement de l'afrique
au crétacé et l'afrique qui est donc
rester isolés pendant tout le
toute la première moitié du cénozoïque
jusqu'à l'oligocène jusqu'à la fin de la
ligue hossein donc au début du miocène
ya un petit pont de terre qui se forme
avec l'eurasie et c'est là que
finalement on va voir de nouveau
mammifère arriver mais sinon les afro
terres en fête ont évolué se sont
diversifiés et ont dominé l'afrique
pendant toute la première moitié du
cénozoïque et ça ça veut dire une chose
importante et qui va peut-être qu'il va
peut-être vous surprendre mais ça veut
dire que en gros avant que là que
l'afrique soit connecté à l'asie il n'y
avait pas de zèbres il n'y avait pas de
lyon il n'y avait pas d'antilopes il y
avait que ça il y avait que ce que je
vous affiche là à l'écran et leurs
ancêtres évidemment et on va voir que on
va voir donc j'ai tout un il ya tout un
cours sur les afro terre et plus
particulièrement les pennons gueulé
c'est à dire l'ensemble proboscidiens
siréniens irak aux ide donc ceux qui ont
un bon registre fossile
j'ai toute une tout un cours sur les
paiements gueulé pendant lesquelles on
va voir que c'est en fait ces groupes là
et notamment les irak au heat qui ont
rempli les rôles de zèbres et de deux
zèbres et d'antilopes pendant le la
première moitié du cénozoïque l'hexane
art rebelle et xena rdsa à peu près la
même chose mais en amérique du sud donc
les xena retrace qui signifie
articulations bizarre donc l'hexane art
trop pourquoi pourquoi articulations
bizarre parce qu'en fait dans les
vertèbres lombaires ils ont une double
articulation donc ce qui veut dire qu en
fait au lieu d'avoir une seule paire
d'articulation dans les vertèbres au
niveau des lombaires en fait ils ont
deux paires d'articulation et ça c'est
très rare chez les mammifères c'est un
caractère qu'on retrouve chez les
serpents donc la double paire
d'articulation entre les vertes mc un
caractère qu'on retrouve quasiment
jamais chez les mammifères
à part celle et xena retr donc les xena
retrait ils doivent leur nom à cette
double paire d'articulation dans les
vertèbres et ils ont d'autres caractères
morphologiques traits distinctifs qui
ils partagent tous donc contrairement
aux afro terre c'est un groupe qui au
niveau morphologiques est assez cohérent
c'est ils ont en plus de cette
articulation ce qu'on appelle un sac
rome
c'est à dire qu'en fait le bassin est
complètement fusionné aux vertèbres
auquel ils s'attachent donc qui
s'appelle les vertèbres les vertèbres
sacré donc le bassin et les vertèbres
sont complètement fusionné et forment un
sacre sommes donc c'est un seul os
cohérent en fait au lieu d'avoir le
bassin un peu détaché en fait c'est un 7
un os qu on retrouve aussi chez les
oiseaux donc encore un caractère un peu
reptilien j'ai envie de dire bon si vous
considérez les oiseaux comme des
reptiles devrais je dire des sceaux
robes side
voilà pour les pour les guérilleros ce
de la khl a dit stick mais voilà c'est
encore un caractère de
qui est très peu commun chez les
mammifères le saint sacrement et ils ont
aussi cette particularité c'est d'avoir
des dents soit tout pourri soit pas
dedans du tout qu'est ce que je veux
dire pas tous pourris c'est qu'ils n'ont
jamais des mailles en fait aux dents et
lord en août une morphologie extrêmement
simple ils ont jamais depuis en fait ils
ont complètement perdu le plan tribos
phoenix donc ils n'ont pas de dents
tribaux ce fait ni qui a toujours de
l'occlusion entre les dents vous pouvez
voir que les dents elles ont toujours
une occlusion les unes avec les autres
mais le la tribu ce fait ni est
complètement perdu et l'émail aussi donc
c'est des dents qui sont uniquement
faite d'ivoire de dentine et donc parmi
c'est parmi les xena donc c'est un
groupe qui est déjà cohérent
morphologiquement et c'est pour ça
qu'ils avaient déjà été reconnus dans
les files au génie morphologiques donc
ça ça n'a pas trop changé et c'est un
groupe qui est aussi cohérent dans son
origine si nab sud américaine et dans sa
distribution toujours sud américaine
donc on y retrouve le groupe
finalement des omnivores qui s'appelle
les singularités qu'on peut tout
simplement appeler les l'état tout le
groupe des herbivores
arboricole qu'on appelle les paresseux
et qui s'appelle les folies vohra en
termes scientifiques et le groupe des
insectivores donc des fourmilier c'est à
dire les vernis lengua vermine un goy
qui révoque du coup la langue vermiforme
des des fourmis liés donc les
fourmiliers sont ceux qui ont
complètement perdu les dents pour les
raisons que j'ai déjà évoqué qu'on en
relation avec le fait d'avaler enfin
d'avoir plein de terre dans la bouche et
d'essayer de mastiquer la terre et donc
pareil même histoire
quelque part au crétacé le
l'ancêtre commun d'exane artres se
retrouve isolé en amérique du sud qui
est restent isolés n'ont pas jusqu'à la
fin du non pas pendant la première
moitié du cénozoïque mais pendant la
quasi-totalité du cénozoïque donc la
connexion que vous voyez l'isthme de
panama que vous ne voyez pas ici encore
apparaître en fait ne va se former qu il
y a deux millions d'années et on verra
dans la
dans le court que j'ai que j'ai préparé
pour juste à propos de l'amérique du sud
en fait ce qui s'est passé en amérique
du sud pour que évoluent des trucs aussi
bizarre que les xena retr mais aussi des
trucs aussi bizarre que tila cosmi luce
parce que faut reconnecter ça aussi avec
ce qui s'est passé chez les marsupiaux
les marsupiaux aussi se sont retrouvées
isolées en amérique du sud
et c'est pour ça qu'on a des trucs aussi
bizarre que tila cosmi luce parce que il
n'y avait pas de carnivores classique en
amérique du sud les jaguars donc les il
n'y avait pas de jaguar il n'y avait pas
de l'ama donc les arts vivants non plus
n'était pas là il n'y avait pas de la
maille avait il y avait d'autres groupes
d'herbivores dont les paresseux mais est
particulièrement les paresseux géant
mais on parlera de tout ça pendant
l'épisode sur l'amérique du sud
là tout ce que je vais vous montrer
c'est que donc on a un isolement qui se
met en place au crétacé avec le
probablement l'ancêtre commun d'exane
art qui se retrouve coincé là et qui se
diversifie dans tous ces groupes
écologiques dont on a parlé les
herbivores les
les anti turs donc les fourmiliers et
les omnivores est le tout premier les
toutes premières traces qu'on a de xena
retrait elles datent de la fin de
l'éocène et il s'agit donc de ce petit
crâne ici qui ressemble beaucoup à celui
d'un à tatouille moderne et de ces ostéo
derme qui ressemble aussi à ceux des
tatous moderne donc
donc donc on a très probablement déjà
des tatous dès la fin de l'éocène donc
ce qui encore une fois pointe du doigt
une origine beaucoup plus ancienne de
l'ancêtre commun d'exane artres le
groupe en bleu maintenant le groupe en
bleu ici en fait il est il regroupe des
les membres de deux classes bien
identifiable donc ce groupe en bleus
s'appelle les oeufs archontes hogli re
et ça c'est probablement mon nom préféré
de tout secours les oeufs archontes haug
lire donc pourquoi le archontes hogli
repasse que ce groupe regroupe ceux clad
regroupe ce qu'on appelle les archontes
et l'aigle here donc les arts compte ce
sont les ceusses on le sait le petit
groupe dans lequel on retrouve les
primates les dernières les secondes
ancien donc le groupe d arboricole et
alors autrefois on plaçait les
chiroptères parmi les archontes mais ce
n'est pas du tout soutenu par les
analyses génétiques donc j'ai mis
chiroptères avec un point
d'interrogation mais en réalité vous
pouvez d'ores et déjà les oublier les
analyses génétiques ne soutiennent pas
du tout que les chiroptères fasse partie
des archontes mais disons que autrefois
les allées chiroptères était placée
parmi les arts contre c'est ce qu'on
pouvait voir dans le premier arbre que
je vous ai montré à propos des
placentaires l'arbre morphologiques et
vous avez les glee redon qui sont les
petits herbivores donc la partie
arboricole du groupe et la partie
herbivores du groupe
donc la partie herbivore du groupe dans
lequel vous retrouvez les lagomorphes
que sont les lapins et les relances ya
c'est à dire les rongeurs donc les
lagomorphes les lapins ne sont pas des
rongeurs déjà première chose à retenir
de ça les lapins sont bien séparées des
rongeurs et appartiennent à leur propre
ordre qui s'appelle les lagomorphes déjà
premières données très importantes
deuxième donnée importante c'est que en
fait de tous ces groupes
il n'y a guère que les primates les
lagomorphes et les rongeurs qui ont un
registre fossile digne de ce nom les
termes aux terres et les secours dans
tia alors vous avez probablement même
jamais entendu parler
aubeterre et d'escrocs nantiat les
dermot terre on les appelle aussi les
call you go et les scandant tiens on les
appelle les to buy
donc voilà ça vous avance 1 au moins
vous savez quoi google et si jamais vous
saviez pas ce qui était un terme aux
termes et un score d'anciens on appelle
aussi les dermot terre on les appelle
aussi les lémuriens volant des fois mais
bon c'est bon voilà les chiroptères ont
un très bon registre fossile mais encore
une fois pas deux ce ne sont pas
vraiment des heures contes aux glières
c'était autrefois considérés comme des
arts compte mais ce n'est plus le cas
donc à l'intérieur des archontes oublir
comme je voulais dire on a un beau
registre fossile des primates qui
remonte jusqu au crétacé avec purgatorio
ce que vous voyez ici apparaître à
l'écran donc purgatorio ce vous voyez en
bas à droite c'est l'os de la cheville
de purgatoire yeux c'était c'était donc
l'archétype encore une fois de du
placentaire paléocène mais il a déjà des
caractères qui le relie au peuple aux
primates
donc on détaillera tout ça dans le cours
qui est spécialement dédié aux primates
ne vous en faites pas mais voilà
purgatorio la seule chose à savoir le
maintenant c'est que purgatorio est le
plus ancien le archontes hogli re
fossiles qu'on aimait et il vient
d'amérique du nord et il vient il
appartient d'ores et déjà à la branche
arts compte des heures contes aux
glières et on a aussi par amis ce qui
lui appartient à la branche glee re des
arts quand on lire c'est à dire du côté
lagomorphes érodant tu es un rongeur de
la force et par à miss vient du
paléocène lui aussi d'amérique du nord
donc pour les eaux archontes au glee on
se dirigerait plutôt vers une origine
nord américaine et là vous commencez à
sentir le pattern qui se forment le clad
rouge c'est les espèces africaines le
clad vers les xena retracer les espèces
sud-américaine le clac bleus c'est les
espèces nord américaine là vous
commencez à sentir qu'il ya un pattern
qui se forment
il ya quelque chose qui est en train de
se produire
on commence à attendre le dénouement de
tout ça et donc le dénouement de tout ça
va venir avec les lots ghazi à terre
donc lors asia teria donc les animaux de
laure asie littéralement
pourquoi parce qu'ils auraient une
origine laurentienne mais le problème
c'est qu'on sait pas exactement si c'est
amérique du nord ou en asie très
probablement asie mais vous allez voir
que le registre fossile est pas si clair
que ça mais bref no spoiler pour
l'instant qu'est ce qu'on trouve chez
les lourds asie à terrebonne et
l'eurasie à terre donc c'est le groupe
qui est le plus diversifié non pas en
nombre d'espèces mais en termes de
diversité écologique
donc pourquoi je dis pas en nombre
d'espèces parce que évidemment les
l'éclade qui contiennent le plus
d'espèces
ce sont les rongeurs et les chiroptères
donc et le problème c'est dans et c'est
dans l'ordre d'abord les rongeurs et
ensuite les chiroptères donc les
rongeurs appartenant au zoo arcand taux
de l'ir il ya en fait plus d'espèces
dollar contre glisse simplement parce
qu'il ya des rongeurs en fait et après
vous avez 300 espèces de primates qui
n'est pas dégueulasse non plus donc
voilà ça ça fait un bond clad mêlée lors
asia terre ils ont les chiroptères il ya
quand même quatre mille espèces et ils
ont laissé tertio dactyle qui ont qui
ont un bon 300 espèces à leur active
aussi
donc voilà c'est quasiment à égalité
entre les le radiateur et les heures
compte ouvrir la différence c'est que
les radiateurs sont très diversifiés du
point de vue écologique donc vous avez
les mammifères volants que sont les
chiroptères et dont la l'affinité
l'eurasia terrienne n'est plus à
démontrer grâce encore une fois la
génétique mais vous avez aussi les
cétacés donc les cétacés qui forme avec
les ars you dactyle le groupe des sept a
reçus au tactile donc on verra pendant
un cours totalement dédié au scénario
dactyle comment ça se fait que
finalement on associe les baleines avec
des espèces terrestres comme les arceaux
dactyle et pourquoi pourquoi celle là
plutôt que n'importe quel autre au final
un parce que finalement
les cétacés ont une origine terrestre
mais pourquoi ce serait parmi les a
reçus au tactile c'est ce que nous
verrons
et puis vous avez aussi d'autres
herbivores comme les périodes active
donc les chevaux et les rhinocéros dans
les arceaux dactyle vous avez tout ce
qui est antilopes vaches ruminants etc
les cochons les hippopotames vous avez
des fourmis liés comme le folie d'hôtes
vous avez des insectivores qui s'appelle
les hollies poti fla donc voilà plutôt
que de les appeler insectes ivorra ils
ont préféré les appeler eux l'ipo tiflet
merci les généticiens pour ce cadeau
voilà non mais il faut savoir que le
simple fait d'enlever les temps rec et
les taupes dorée des insectivores a
poussé les généticiens à renommer le
groupe des insectivores les hollies
petit fla avant ça s'appelait les
insectivores a donc même si aujourd'hui
il ya toujours que des insectivores
parmi l'élite au tiff là faut quand même
les appeler eux l'ipo tiflet donc c'est
pour ça que je dis merci aux généticiens
mais bref
et vous avez bien sûr les carnivores
donc niveau type écologique qui sont
plus diversifiés du coup que les afro
terre parce qu'il ya des volants et des
carnivores voilà et le registre fossile
de ces lots razia teria remonte
jusqu'aux paléocène avec la possibilité
que proton bull at home soit relie soit
à relier avec les avec les lots razia
teria mais ça c'est pas évident non mais
si proton gül à tom est un lot razia
teria ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait
aussi du lot razia teria au crétacé et
proton bull at home
vient d'amérique du nord comme les
condyles artres a donc comme ce qu'on
dit la retraite voici ce qu'on appelle
un conte dit la retraite un cetain
ondulé primitif on va dire mais ce qu'on
dit larqué en particulier qui s'appelle
fenaco du sang fait a ceci de
particulier qu'il a le doigt du milieu
qui est plus gros que les autres ce qui
est un caractère typique des périseaux
dactyle donc des rhinocéros et des
chevaux les chevaux n'ont même plus que
le doigt du milieu en réalité donc donc
il se pourrait que fenaco du ce soit en
fait un proche parent des chevaux ce qui
ferait de lui un des plus anciens un des
plus anciens lors asia teria et vous
avez himalaya cetus du paléocène d'asie
qui est aussi l'un des plus anciens
l'eurasia terriens et là pour le coup
c'est un cétacé comme le dit le nom
himalaya cetus donc vous pouvez voir que
himalaya cetus ressemble beaucoup
si vous connaissez pas qui s'est tue
souvent bulot cetus vous pouvez voir
qu'il leur ressemble beaucoup
c'est normal c'est parce que il est à
peu près du il est même un peu plus
vieux que pas qui c'est us mais il
ressemble davantage à un bel os et us
kapakis et us mais ça c'est une autre
histoire
de toute façon la voilà c'est le seul
fossiles qu'on a des himalayas et us
donc là je vous donne ça c'est juste
pour vous mettre l'eau à la bouche pour
le cours sur les scénarios d'actes il
est aussi pour vous encourager à aller
voir le cours sur les cétacés que
j'avais dit que j'avais fait il y a de
cela 5 ans je crois cours qui est
toujours en ligne
il est alors je l'avais remis à jour il
ya cinq ans mais bon depuis cinq ans il
ya évidemment des choses qui sont
ressorties mais globalement il ya juste
plus d'espèces dont d'auto cette base al
qu' il y a cinq ans parce qu'il ya des
groupes qui se sont mis à beaucoup bossé
sur les cétacés mais voilà tout ce que j
10 est toujours vrai voilà c'est juste
que maintenant la diversité de certains
groupes à changer voilà les eaux d'auto
cette base eau
exane or oxydé voilà notamment sont
beaucoup plus diverses
maintenant qu'ils ne l'étaient il ya
cinq ans et l'origine des mysticètes
aussi a été repoussée à à l'eocène
supérieur ce qui n'était pas ce qui de
même n'était pas encore le cas il ya
cinq ans mais voilà c'est du détail quoi
tout ce que j'ai dit tout ce qui est
morphologie par exemple écologie n'a pas
changé risque pas de changer de sitôt
donc voilà le cours est toujours en
ligne
je vous encourage à aller le voir si
l'évolution des cétacés vous intéresse
mais on en reparlera de toute façon pour
l'évolution des arts cieux dactyle donc
voilà ce qu'on sait ce que je vous
disais donc on a le possiblement les
plus vieux fossiles et en amérique du
nord et en asie donc c'est pour ça que
ça s'appelle les lots razia teria c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu se décider en
fait de quel continent de lalo ghazi
venez les lots razia teria voilà mais il
est fort probable qu'ils aient une
origine asiatique ce qui ce qui du coup
nous amène dit je vais directement
sauter à sept diapos là ce qui du coup
nous amène à cette diapos là où
finalement vous avez une
une une division des mammifères qui
n'est pas tant écologique c'est-à-dire
rappelez vous la morphologie ce que nous
disait la morphologie c'est que vous
aviez les herbivores les insectivores
les arboricole et les petits et les
petits airs beevor qui était bien
séparés en fait cette division a serait
pas écologique mais en fait elle serait
très fortement contrainte par le la
dérive des continents
donc vous avez les continents qui se
séparent pendant le mésozoïque donc là
lors asie enfin l'europe et l'asie qui
se sépare de l'amérique du nord pendant
le jurassique pendant la fin du
jurassique et l'amérique du sud et
l'afrique qui se séparent au crétacé et
qui se sépare aussi de de lalo ghazi de
la laure asie donc la pangée qui se
disloque
au final c'est ni plus ni moins que ça
et bien pendant la dislocation de cette
page et il y a les ancêtres de chacun
des groupes qui se sont retrouvées
isolées sur chacun de ces blocs
conduisant donc à l'évolution
complètement convergente des mêmes types
écologique donc en afrique vous allez
avoir des grands herbivores des espèces
marines des petits herbivores des
familiers et des insectivores et en m et
dans la moitié nord vous allez avoir des
grands herbivores des fours milliers d
petit insectivore des espèces marines
et puis vous allez avoir des arboricole
et en amérique du sud vous allez aussi
avoir un autre les mêmes types
écologique donc les les fourmiliers les
arboricole et puis on va voir tous les
autres groupes qui se sont diversifiées
aussi en amérique du sud comme je
voulais dia les marsupiaux qui ne sont
pas des placentaires donc ils ne sont
pas représentés ici mais évidemment les
marsupiaux vont occuper la niche des
carnivores du nord l'est et des groupes
comme les méridiens gül et on va voir
ont occupé les niches des herbivores
donc voilà ça c'est donc l'histoire des
placentaires en fait si elle n'a aucun
sens du point de vue morphologique elle
fait totalement sens du point de vue
biogéographique du point de vue de la de
la cassure finalement de la pangée et ça
c'est quand même vachement cool
alors oui je sais ce que vous allez me
dire cette image est fausse parce que du
coup ils ont mis les heures quand au
clair sur l'asie et les lots razia
thérias sur l'amérique du nord alors que
ça devrait être l'inversé
oui je sais je sais mais c'est quand
même ça reste quand même l'image la plus
visuellement parlante que j'ai pu
trouver sur le sujet voilà je suis au
courant merci après là l'une des grandes
questions qui s'est posée mais là je
vais aller très vite là dessus c'est en
gros quel groupe et ont relié avec qui
parce que là je vous ai montré les
quatre groupes à frotter ria xena retr à
new york en tongs liars donc les heures
quant aux glières et les lots razia
teria mais évidemment ça veut pas dire
que ces groupes seront forcément dans ce
cadre là alors on est à peu près sûr que
les lots razia teria et les arcs auto
glee reforme un clad qu'on appelle les
boréaux et arias mais après il ya des
petits doutes sur vous ce maître les
xena retrait les affreux tard ya donc
vous avez deux hypothèses basiquement
l'hypothèse où celles et xena retr les
plus bazzo les afro teria qui sont
groupe frère dé boréaux teria hypothèse
qui s'appelle donc les épis teria et
vous avez l'hypothèse où il y aller
boréaux et où les afro teria son groupe
frère d'exane art rats
et qui s'appelle l'hypothèse atlante
auger natta je présente pas l'hypothèse
exo afro placental ya parce que
globalement c'est une des moins soutenue
on va dire donc il ya encore des doutes
à ce propos la donc léger les analyses
génétiques sont pas toutes très très
claires de ce point de vue là il ya des
contradictions donc l'arbre que je vous
montre depuis tout à l'heure
soutient les exos frau près le placenta
lia depuis le début c'est ça que je vous
montre
mais en réalité déjà mais en réalité
voilà il ya débat il ya débat c'est tout
les atlantes auger natanya pas beaucoup
de soutien du point de vue de la
génétique mais il y a l'avantagent que
quand on regarde la distribution
géographique en fait ben on aurait un
clad qui correspondrait à l'ancien
gondwana et ça c'est cool comme on sait
que le gondwana s'est séparé du reste
enfin quand on sait que les deux blocs
du gondwana ne se sont séparés au
crétacé ça aurait du sens de placer les
deux clad issus du gondwana dans le même
clad en fête est donc là les atlantes
auger natta ferez sens du point de vue
géographique mais par contre ce qui fait
sens du point de vue morphologique c'est
les épis teria parce que parce que quand
on regarde finalement le quand on
regarde la morphologie des afro terre et
des bourgs et au teria bas ils partagent
un caractère qui est la réduction de la
fibula qui ne quitte donc ne touche ne
s'articulent plus avec le fémur donc
voici le tibia d'un
voici le tibia d'un data to donc d'un
xena retr et voici sa fille du live vous
voyez que ça fibula s'étend jusqu'en
haut du tibia et donc s'articule ici
avec le fémur on voit bien la facette
d'articulation du fémur par contre quand
on regarde les autres les autres animaux
les autres mammifères bas on voit que la
fibula est en fait un tout petit os
réduit et que l'articulation avec le
fémur appartient au tibia et voilà ça se
voit donc ça c'est un tarsier ça c'est
un lapin ça c'est un chimpanzé à chaque
fois vous voyez la fibula est tout petit
réduite et ne s'articulent finalement
qu'avec et ne s'articulent qu'avec le
tibia et que le tibia lui-même
s'articule avec le fémur
donc voila voila le toute l'histoire
donc les épis teria serait soutenu par
plus de données morphologiques et plus
de données génétiques en dhr donc on se
dirigerait plutôt vers un dénouement
épique teria de du débat alors en
conclusion
en conclusion ben pourquoi s'intéresser
à ce point aux mammifères placentaires
ben comme je le disais parce que déjà
ils sont beaucoup plus diversifiée donc
on va on va passer dias directement à
cette diapos la voilà ils sont beaucoup
plus diversifiée vous pouvez voir ici
donc le
le compte des espèces j'ai dit alors
tout à l'heure j'ai dit à 5000 espèces
de rongeurs non il n'ya pas 5000 espèces
de rongeurs autant pour moi il ya 1500
espèces de rongeurs il y avait une
histoire de 5 mais ce n'était pas le bon
autant pour moi je fais des bêtises je
dis des bêtises
donc il ya 1500 espèces de rongeurs mea
culpa il ya mille deux cent quarante
espèces de chauves-souris et donc vous
pouvez voir les marsupiaux ils sont là
voilà les marsupiaux ses 6 % de la
diversité donc même pas 300 espèces en
gros ça veut dire qu'il ya moins de
marsupiaux qu'il n'ya de primates
je sais pas si vous considérez les
primates comme un groupe extrêmement
diversifiée mais si c'est le cas
mais si c'est pas le cas ben voilà les
marsupiaux sont encore moins diversifiés
que les primates et pourtant il s'agit
d'un groupe qui du point de vue
taxonomique est censé être comparable au
placentaire donc la diversité des
mammifères modernes est largement
dominée par celle par parler placentaire
et ça ça à plusieurs implications donc
déjà bas vu qu'il ya beaucoup de
mammifères placentaires et comme il se
fossilise très bien et comme les espèces
peuvent être différenciées rien que sur
la base de la morphologie dentaire bas
on peut tracer des l'évolution de ces
placentaire à travers le temps et à
travers la stratigraphie comme ici dans
le paléo scène d'amérique du nord de
façon extrêmement précise et ça permet
de voir par exemple des lignées
évolutives sans avoir même affaire de
cladistique dont vous imaginez là on a
juste la mesure de la de la molaire donc
c'est la longueur x largeur de la
molaire est juste en en faisant un
diagramme de la longueur x largeur de la
molaire dans une série de faux cils
ramassé sur cette colonne
stratigraphique du paléocène on arrive à
voir
la divergence de ligne et voiliers de
ligne et pouf trois lignes et pour
quatre lignes et pouf cinq lignes et et
ça et ça je trouve ça assez formidable
ça veut dire qu'on peut voir la
spéciation en temps réel avec les
placentaire et ça ça troue le cul voilà
je suis désolé il faut dire les choses
comme elles sont ça troue le cul
on peut voir la spéciation en direct
avec des places interne et et on n'a
même pas besoin là là c'est même pas une
analyse fine effet netiq ça s'appelle
une analyse stratos
ça s'appelle une analyse pardon je
répète strato frénétique
donc c'est vraiment mais la base
vraiment c'est juste un caractère et on
met ça sur la colonne strati et boum ça
fait des chocapics c'est juste
absolument formidable alors évidemment
du coup au niveau de la stratigraphie on
va avoir des grandes tendances et la
grande tendance est évidemment la
séparation du cénozoïque en deux parties
le palais aux le le paléogène et le
néogène est en fait cette séparation du
cénozoïque en deux parties paléogène et
néogène bas c'est finalement la
séparation entre la dominance de groupes
archaïque de deux placentaire et la
dominance des groupes modernes de
placentaire donc les groupes archaïque
vous avez les condyles artres vous avez
les plaisirs d'api forme les méta teria
donc les marsupiaux qui était répandue
de par le monde mais finalement vont
finir réduit à l'australie à la et à la
ala l'amérique du sud vous avez les
multis tubercules et qu'il ya un groupe
venant directement du mésozoïque qui ne
sont même pas des m'as malia au sens
strict en tout cas pas donc pas d'après
tout le monde mais qui sont des maliens
à former en tout cas d'emma malia forme
du mésozoïque qui survivent pendant la
première moitié du palais du du
cénozoïque donc pendant le paléogène et
pouf finisse par s'éteindre à la moitié
voilà pouf du palais du du cénozoïque
donc voilà c'est cette séparation des
groupes taxonomiques entre qui définit
finalement cette tranche de temps en
fait on va voir que cette tranche de
tence cette séparation entre le néo
gênes et le paléogène on la retrouve
dans plein d'événements plein plein
d'événements de la vie des mammifères
donc ça va être ça coïncide aussi avec
la première glaciation de la grande
glaciation de la fin de ligue hossein
fin de la ligue hossein en général ça
coïncide aussi avec avec les cétacés qui
commence à devenir un groupe dominant
dans les mers ça coïncide aussi avec la
rupture de la deûle isolement de
l'afrique ça coïncide avec les l'herbe
qui se répand à travers le monde les
grassland donc les savanes et les
steppes qui se répandent à travers le
monde non bref c'est il ya un gros il ya
une grosse crise et que je hais je suis
même très surpris d'ailleurs que cette
crise soit pas considérée comme étant
une crise d'extinction de masse au même
titre que la crise de la fin du paléo
gêne parce que c'est vraiment du gros du
gros événements qui se passent entre le
palais aux gènes est menée aux gènes
donc voilà un autre exemple de comment
la les mammifères sont utilisés en
biostratigraphie donc vous avez la
colonne stratigraphique vous avez les
étages et ici vous avez la division
basée sur les mammifères donc mn ça veut
dire mammalian et
j'aime ce stage donc voilà on utilise
des faunes de mammifères pour dater et
finalement vous voyez que c'est datation
sont presque plus passer ces tranches
bio stratigraphique sont plus petites
que les étages que vous pouvez voir au
dessus donc on peut faire des tranches
stratigraphique beaucoup plus fine grâce
au foehn de mammifères que grâce à la
lithologie ou à quoi que ce soit d'autre
donc ça c'est quand même assez
formidable on peut étudier les
extinctions bien entendu je vais pas
m'étaler là-dessus on peut étudier les
paléoenvironnements et ça on le verra
avec les ongulés les herbivores et
notamment la hauteur des dents des
herbivores va directement être un reflet
du paléo environnement donc la
transition depuis des milieux fermés de
feu et forestier jusqu'à des milieux
ouverts donc de savane est un exemple
voilà exemples de transition depuis
milieu forestier jusqu'à milieu de
savane l'afrique
bien entendu qui était complètement
couvertes de forêts donc ça c'est léo
cède c'est le minot seine inférieure et
qui depuis le mi hossein inférieur en
fait devient de plus en plus arides donc
commençant par le sud puisque le sud est
plus proche de l'antarctique donc
forcément est moins sujet aux
précipitations et puis voilà ça va se
réduire ça va se réduire
jusqu'au point où voilà on va finir avec
avec le climat moderne quoi donc voilà
celle aventure que je vous propose de
suivre pendant tout cet été l'évolution
des mammifères donc
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
avec l'évolution des arts sio dactyle et
des périseaux dactyle donc l'évolution
des ancêtres des chevaux des rhinocéros
des vaches des cochons des hippopotames
et des cétacés
voilà à la semaine prochaine ciao